Good morning
and welcome to Omaha.
I want to welcome all our owners, our
our long-term owners, those that have
recently become a shareholder. Again,
thank you for joining us in Omaha for
this for for the for the meeting.
Obviously very excited by this and I
want to also touch on what many people
here just experiencing it. So,
uh
just great to be together.
The first thing I just want to touch on,
we had the video, incredible 60 years.
The one thing I did know that we've
traditionally had was we've often had a
movie which included the credits that
came with it. And
the move the video and the we'll have a
few other videos I'll touch on later,
but we did have a
uh an exceptional producer executive
producer and I want to thank her cuz she
it wasn't acknowledged. Susie Buffett,
thank you.
And then the director who's always done
the movies, again did this video and
will do our company videos that I'll
touch on shortly.
Uh Brad Underwood, thank you, Brad.
Now, we have a great day planned and
it's really all around our owners. It's
our culture, but most importantly this
is our owners' day,
our owners' weekend.
Uh we have an exceptional group of
owners and
we're just passionate to be here. We'll
communicate
a variety of things around Berkshire and
and our and our insurance or operating
subsidiaries and and the and Berkshire
as a whole, but what we really treasure
is the engagement with our again our
owners, our shareholders and the and the
questions that come. So, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Now, the touch on this morning,
we have three sessions that will will
will cover over the morning early
afternoon.
The first session, there'll be some
pleasantries here, and then we'll move
into a business update.
Uh that'll be the first session. As we
move into the second session, I'll have
Ajit Jain join us here on stage. We'll
obviously take any questions, so it'll
be a a question and answer period. We'll
do the traditional
uh rotating between our shareholders and
Becky. Becky, thank you for being here.
Um and we'll do the traditional Q&A.
And then that session will wrap, and
then we'll move to a third session that
will have Katie Farmer.
Katie is a been the uh CEO of
BNSF, our railway, for for the past 5
years. And then we'll also be joined by
Adam Johnson, who is a uh
10-year CEO 10-year CEO of uh NetJets,
but also took on a an incremental role
recently, and uh we announced that in
December. Adam took on the consumer
products group services and retailing
group. So, we'll have them join us for
the third session. Again, the
traditional question and answer period.
The only thing that I would I would say
this is also a little bit incremental or
uh different from past uh meetings.
Throughout this morning, we'll have
three different videos
uh
associated with operating companies.
Uh
the first one will be from Geico,
Nancy Pierce, who's the CEO of of Geico,
long-term
uh
veteran and wealth of experience with
Geico. She's over in the manager
section. She'll she'll narrate a video
on Geico.
And then we'll also have a video on
NetJets narrated by Adam and a video
narrated
by Katie on BNSF, the railway. So
that'll that'll be incremental. Now,
the fundamental purpose of both having
the some incremental managers join us on
the stage and the videos, we have an
exceptional team at Berkshire.
The depth of management's very deep.
Obviously, we have a number of
subsidiaries, but the depth of our team
is great. And this is an opportunity
through the videos or having incremental
leaders on stage, it's an it's an
opportunity for you as our owners to
both learn more about those businesses,
but also about the leaders that lead
them.
And that will be a format that as we go
forward, we'll build on. I we can
introduce you to other leaders either on
stage or through the through the videos.
So,
let's move to the formalities now. I'm
going to introduce our our directors.
I'm going to do it alphabetically. So,
if they could just uh
acknowledge with a wave or however they
would like to acknowledge our our
shareholders, our owners.
Start with Howard Buffett.
Susie Buffett.
>> Our chairman, Warren Buffett.
Warren, we have a little surprise there
for you.
If you look up to the right, you'll see
a jersey
and a number. We are We are retiring
Warren, appropriately it's number 60 for
60 years as our CEO of Berkshire.
Equally, it's being
It's It's placed beside Charlie's
jersey, number 45. Charlie was with
Berkshire for 45 years. Obviously, our
vice chairman and a treasured partner of
Warren, and it's just reflective of a
great partnership. Thank you, Warren.
I'm happy to report both those jerseys
will remain in the rafters
for the years to come, so
great.
Now, I'll continue with our directors,
Steve Burke.
Ken Chenault.
Chris Davis.
Our lead director,
and I'll just add a point here cuz
it's Sue's 20th year as a director of
Berkshire. Thank you for being our lead
director and all you do, Sue Decker.
Charlotte Guyman.
Ajit Jain.
I would just add for
relative to Ajit, obviously been our
vice chairman for of insurance for 9
years. I had many years to be as as
co-chairman, but one thing I just want
to touch on, Ajit joined Berkshire in
1986. So, not only is he a director,
just been really the architect of our
insurance business. So, again, thank
you, Ajit.
Tom Murphy Jr.
Wally Weitz.
Meryl Witmer.
Now, I I can start to I think my eyes
have adjusted a bit to the lights and
everyone out there, and I I have to tell
a little bit of a story here because
when when Warren announced the
transition last year and I was sitting
here and couldn't been
more proud but I don't mind sharing the
first thing that flashed through my mind
was geez we've already booked this arena
and
I
I know the directors would be here and I
knew I would have some family here
but it's wonderful to all have you here
so thank you.
Thank you.
Now
back to a great tradition.
I'm going to throw the mic over to
Warren. Warren?
>> Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's It's This is not my show
today but there are two
uh
Well there there there there two
anniversaries
uh
that uh
we're kind of celebrating today. One is
the fact that the uh
the uh
board has had what
I will uh
generously call a refreshment uh
which they voted and
uh
you couldn't have made a better
decision.
Uh
they did it unanimously. It was a
surprise to all the board when I
announced it last year. It kept uh
for Susie and Ollie uh
and uh
uh
that's been a 100% successful.
Greg is doing
uh
everything I did and then some and he's
doing it better in all cases and he's
got
he's he's the right person. So, that
decision
we score 100% on. Uh
>> Thank you, Warren.
Thank you.
>> But, there's another anniversary
today that uh
uh I'd like to
spend just a minute telling you about
because uh
about 10 years ago
we made a commitment uh
to essentially
move 10% of the resources
of
Berkshire Hathaway
uh
we turned it over to another
uh person who was not
that well known at the time.
And we did that
uh
by spending
uh roughly $35 billion
uh buying
uh stock in Apple Corp.
And
uh
and
we were going to have that
uh
under the management
we're we're
turning that money over to the
management essentially of
Apple to make Berkshire look good.
And without any work by us, which is
our preferred way of operating. And
I would like to report that 10 years
later
several things are happening.
One is
the $35 billion
uh
counting dividends, realized
appreciation, unrealized appreciation
but that has turned into a 185 billion
uh
in tax.
And uh
and I didn't have to do a damn thing.
So, it it it uh
it's
you know,
we're very big around here on having
other people do the work.
And uh
but that that has been
uh
a success and we we do look at
marketable securities
as being businesses. That doesn't mean
we hold all of them forever.
But, we still our largest holding is
Apple.
And Apple has
a very interesting history that some of
you may be familiar with, but one one
item is that they're they're
they're observing an anniversary.
Some of us, I think, just within the
last week or so.
Uh they they celebrated their 50th
anniversary and uh
uh
you know, 50 years is
seems like a long time, but Apple seems
like a very new company. And
when Tim Cook
went into
uh the top position
at Apple,
uh
he's
he succeeded
a legend.
Uh
you know, that it uh
uh
Steve Jobs was
everybody in America knew his name.
And not many people knew Tim's name.
And
Apple had had this
roller coaster experience where
where uh
the two Steves had
started in a garage or something 50
years earlier and
and then
I'm not sure how many of you know but
but
Steve was thrown out for a while.
He came back in.
He did these marvelous things in terms
of
developing products.
Uh and then he had an untimely
uh death
and uh
everybody said
who's going to manage
Apple when Steve Jobs isn't around and
uh
probably
just a
very few percentage points
of American investors had even heard of
Tim Cook.
And
we in effect
Tim took over about 14 years ago
when when when uh
Steve died.
But when we made our investment
uh
and turned over 10% of the resources
of Berkshire
uh
we were turning it over to Tim.
And
as I say he
has turned that into
185 billion or something pre-tax
which we won't bother to compare to
our record with. Uh
and but Tim has announced
that he's
uh
retiring as well.
That's just That's an announcement
that's just been made in the last couple
of years.
And so I think it's appropriate
if if Tim would take a bow and our
shareholders would say
thanks to him. That's
Tim is right by me.
I wouldn't want to step into the shoes
of Steve
and come through with his record. I'd be
It's one of the miracles of
of American business management. And so,
anyway, thank you
Tim, and I'm going to turn things back
to uh
to Greg and we'll go on from there.
>> Warren.
Woo.
Tim, on behalf of our shareholders and
owners here, we echo everything Warren
said. And and I would add one thing.
You've truly been a global ambassador
around the world for American business.
Thank you.
And Warren, thank you for taking the mic
there. I am reminded I have a cherry
Coke chair
in your honor, peanut brittle in
Charlie's honor, and that seat remains
open.
Thank you, Warren.
Now, we'll move to a little more a few
more more a few more formalities and get
into the uh business update.
Really started with the letter to our
owners and and shareholders at the end
of February.
And I touched on it in the letter. I
highlighted that the first thing as I as
we transitioned, I wrote a letter to our
400,000 employees touching on culture
and values.
And the purpose of that letter was to
highlight
that was not going to change. It had
never changed in Berkshire under
Warren's 60 years.
Aspects of evolved, but it they don't
our our our culture and values did not
change. And that as we did the
transition,
that was not going to change either.
It's the bedrock of Berkshire, that
culture and values.
Now,
um one of the values we've often touched
on here is integrity.
There's no better example of Warren's
remarkable demonstration of that when he
testified before Congress in 1991
as the chairman and CEO of Salomon
Brothers.
I like to call it Berkshire's anthem,
but I wanted to uh make sure we we we
had that opportunity to um see the video
today. Berkshire's Berkshire's anthem.
>> I thank you for the opportunity to
appear before this subcommittee.
I would like to start by apologizing for
the acts that have brought us here.
The nation has a right to expect its
rules and laws to be obeyed.
And at Salomon certainly these were
broken.
Almost all of Salomon's 8,000 employees
regret this as deeply as I do.
And I apologize on their behalf as well
as mine.
My job is to deal with both the past and
the future.
The past actions of Salomon are
presently causing our 8,000 employees
and their families to bear a stain.
Virtually all of these employees are
hard working, able, and honest.
I want to find out exactly what happened
in the past so that this stain is born
by the guilty few and removed from the
innocent.
To help do this, I promised to you, Mr.
Chairman,
and to the American people,
Solomon's wholehearted cooperation with
all authorities.
These authorities have the power
of subpoena,
the ability to immunize witnesses,
and the power to prosecute for perjury.
Our internal investigation has not had
these tools.
We welcome their use.
As to the future,
the submission to this subcommittee
details actions that I believe will make
Solomon the leader within the financial
services industry and controls and
compliance procedures.
But in the end, a spirit about
compliance is as important or more so
than words about compliance.
I want the right words, and I want the
full range of internal controls.
But I also have asked every Solomon
employee to be his or her own compliance
officer.
After they first obey all rules, I then
want employees to ask themselves
whether they are willing to have any
contemplated act
appear the next day on the front page of
their local paper
to be read by their spouses, children,
and friends
with the reporting done by an informed
and critical reporter.
If they follow this test, they need not
fear my other message to them.
Lose money for the firm and I will be
understanding. Lose a shred of
reputation for the firm and I will be
ruthless.
I welcome your questions.
>> Berkshire's anthem, that's embedded in
Berkshire.
We send a reminder to our It's a great
reminder to our CEOs and employees, our
400,000 employees, and and we do
uh
remind them of that, including
I ask our CEOs each year, just sent a
letter and again in in in the first
quarter, asking them as they run their
business,
as they make those daily decisions they
make,
apply that simple test that Warren
highlighted, the news- newspaper test.
Now,
moving to the more formal update on our
numbers,
we in fine tradition, we always start
with our exhibit hall sales from the uh
exhibit hall yesterday, and
uh
the the interesting thing is uh last
year was a record, as you may guess, but
fortunately this year's sales um
were very consistent with 2014. We're
We're basically at 1 and 1/2 million
sales, but the the point is we'd always
love to get to 2 million, and we're not
there yet. So, we've got something to
work on.
Um
But but importantly, what the what the
exhibit hall represents is our
businesses showing their products and
services, and you get to see this great
commitment of our of our leadership
team, and their passion for Berkshire,
and their passion for the owners.
I was fortunate to spend some time going
through the exhibit hall yesterday,
and that's a wonderful experience,
because I get to
We're We're We're getting the
opportunity to engage with all of you as
owners. So, um love We We We treasure
the exhibit hall, and what a what a
great experience, and I'll just add it's
open till 4:00 today, and feel free to
spend a little money.
Now,
truly moving to the more formal aspects
of the business update, we issued our
10-Q this morning, and had the related
press release.
You You see the results, and I'll I'll
touch on those.
Uh I'll start with Berkshire just as a
whole.
Obviously, we have our insurance as as
I've referenced as our heart
of heart of Berkshire was our
foundation.
But, as we move to the non-insurance
businesses,
we're really fortunate to have
a number of businesses in there, but in
their aggregate, they're fundamental
and and really central to American
businesses and American industry and to
the American consumer.
And when I combine those, it's really
the unique opportunity we have to excel
across those businesses, and and that
will continue. It's been our focus, and
it'll very much continue to be our
focus.
If I start by looking at these results,
I'll start with the insurance, total
insurance.
And I'm starting there cuz there's a
couple of really important points to
make.
You can see in 2026, the first quarter
we're actually up
quarter on quarter.
And yet in the letter that I sent out
just in
February,
highlighted the fact that we're unlikely
to see stronger results in 2026.
But, there are some important points
here.
In 2025,
we have an $860 million
after-tax
charge associated with California
wildfires that we insured.
The adjustment's not so important. It's
just to highlight that the 2026 results
and what we're feeling
in the insurance
uh
industry right now, there's two things.
One, our 2026 results
do not reflect any cast catastrophic
events.
It was a pretty benign period. There
were some storms in the northeast part
of the United States, but relative to
2025 and past years, very benign.
And and that highlights again that the
insurance our insurance businesses, but
the the industry as a whole
the pricing we've talked about that
hardening. I can you get the proper
premium for risk?
It's it's becoming a more challenging
market.
What's driving that?
Oh, when you see a benign environment
and I'll touch on further results
another layer, but you start to see
competition coming into the industry.
They bring a broad a variety of products
and forms, but it's really they're
bringing capital into the industry. So,
just wanted to really highlight we still
see that as a softening market and I'll
expand on that.
Now, when we discuss insurance, we all
we have two core objectives at
Berkshire.
We want to underwrite at a profit.
So, create a profit for our ultimately
first year holders, but
truly underwrite at a combined ratio and
I'll come back to it cuz there's a lot
of insurance jargon here and there's a
lot of numbers. So, I'll come back to it
and then the second core objective is to
increase our float.
Now, the insurance jargon and and the
numbers on here
go to the combined ratio on the left and
go way over to the right, the 10-year
average 93%.
I'll give you a little bit of color
here.
If we have a $100 premium that comes in
associated with a policy,
the 93%
represents the costs incurred associated
with that premium. It can be the cost of
writing the premium, the commissions, or
the loss reserve we set up.
The 7% i.e. $7 on $100
is our
is our profit or operating profit on
that premium.
And then if I go back to the $93,
just roughly $23 of that would be the
expenses, the administration of of
running the business. And that's that's
just an average.
It varies across our businesses and it
across it varies across the uh
the the industry.
The other $70,
and this is very important, that's
actually what goes down into float.
So, when I you see our float growing, we
take that $70, it goes into our float,
and we'll incur premiums against it over
the years to come.
And when the premium shows up,
we pay out against that 70. But if you
take a simple small commercial business
or personal insurance,
that that $70 effectively gets paid out
likely over a 3-to-4-year period.
That premium sits there as float.
We earn on it, and Warren's referenced
it many times many times. It's a valued
part of of Berkshire and and and it's
really the opportunity to continue to
create value for for you as our owners
and and shareholders.
You can see on the float,
we've going back to 2015,
it's effectively doubled through 2025.
There's a small increase in the current
quarter, but
I wouldn't I I wanted you to all see it,
but it it it's not
uh the fact it increased, it could have
decreased
because it's just subject to the payment
cycle we're in. The really core and
important objective is that we grow it
over the long run, and we'll continue to
provide those type of updates to you as
our as our owners.
Now, if I go back up to the underwriting
results
and you see the combined ratio again,
but we'll we'll focus on 2026.
Um
primary and reinsurance
they're both 87% 89.6%.
The amazing thing there is that there's
an eight
in that number.
You can again, our 10-year average is in
the 93% so we're actually realizing more
operating insurance income profit there.
Again,
what's driving that? A very benign
environment. When you think of the
catastrophic environment we insure into.
The last time there was a hurricane that
hit landfall in the US
was 19 months ago.
So our our quarterly results, our
results last year do not reflect those
type of outcomes.
Again, that means we have more capital
coming into that industry.
Yes, we like those results, but the
reality is as that business start as our
insurance business softens
and we cannot realize the value we
should for the related risk
Ajit and our insurance team across the
businesses, we start writing less
premium.
We still want to write it at an
underwriting profit cuz well, there's
still opportunities there and there's
there's a number of risk we want to
insure but we'll be much more cautious
and specifically across the the primary
and reinsurance businesses.
Now, let's move to GEICO.
As I highlighted, we have a new CEO.
We're fortunate to have Nancy leading
that team.
Um they even have a better combined
ratio, 87.3%.
That means associated with that business
12% plus operating income coming off of
each dollar of premium we write there.
Um, exceptional result.
What's driven that is that four or five
years ago
we the GEICO team stepped back
and said that they felt they weren't
um, relative to the risk getting the
proper premium, the proper price for
risk.
And over the last four years
we've seen a bet we have worked hard,
the GEICO team worked hard to get the
proper balance across that. That meant
our premiums went up for our customers
across certain classes of of of drivers.
We they worked hard to segment that
customer. And by the way, that happened
across the the auto industry. Generally
speaking, you saw saw an increase in in
the overall premium as they they managed
that underlying risk.
Again, what's that mean to the industry?
What's that mean to GEICO?
Well, one, there's a lot of folks out
there pursuing those customers.
Anytime you increase a customer's
insurance premium
and and especially over a period of
time, and this is I'm talking about both
GEICO and our competitors,
listen, people start evaluating
and shopping. And we've we've seen
unprecedented shopping activity across
the auto space. And you see the
advertising that's out there. They're
pursuing customers and they're pursuing
the GEICO customers.
So yes, we
there there's a an important balance I
want to highlight to to all of you is
that and this is what our GEICO team's
working on.
Yes, we have to get the price to risk
right.
But there's two other important things
we really need to balance.
The second piece is we really do want to
retain our customers. There's no more
valued customer than our GEICO
customers.
Many of you as shareholders and owners
of Berkshire are GEICO customers.
We want to retain all of you. We want to
retain every GEICO customer.
So, as we found that right price to
risk, the next challenge is making sure
we retain our customers and Nancy and
her team have that as a clear objective
and they're working hard on that. And
then the third piece to that balance is
to grow GEICO.
How do we measure growth growth in that
industry? It's policies in force.
And if I touch on
uh
what we've experienced as growth in
GEICO, if we go back to last quarter
2025 versus this quarter
uh
ending March of uh this year, our
policies in force grew by 2%.
Um now
uh compare that to a com- uh the number
one competitor in our industry,
Progressive, they just announced their
first quarter results.
They grew by 11%.
And our team at GEICO fully acknowledge,
as I said, that balance that they have
to find across those
uh the the three metrics including
including growth. It's not going to be
easy to just restart the growth engine.
We acknowledge that. But they understand
the objective and as we go through '26
and into 2027,
two important
um objectives, as I said they have they
have, is uh okay, let's retain our
customers and let's
um start growing GEICO
uh again.
The last thing I'll just touch on the
insurance business and it's uh
um Tokyo Marine.
I'm not going to expand a lot, but other
than we announced the transaction in the
fourth quarter of I mean in the fourth
week of March. A great transaction by
Ajit and his team and and it's a
strategic transaction in that and I'm
highlighting that because yes, there's a
financial aspect of it and we're
thrilled with that, but it is a
long-term strategic partnership and when
Ajit's on stage, I'll have him I'll have
him expand on that. So, well done Ajit
and thank you to you and your team. A
great great transaction for Berkshire.
Now, move to our our non-insurance
businesses.
I'll start with BNSF.
As I've highlighted a number of our
non-insurance businesses provide
critical product services. BNSF is a
great example of that. 32,500
miles of track in the west moving core
products for a number of customers that
touch every industry
in the in the US.
Um,
you'll see the results some some
improvement there, but what we really
want to highlight today and and Katie
will be joining me on stage and and
she'll touch on this
is that
um, we we have a lot lot of work we know
to do at BNSF. We have a great group of
employees that have been working very
hard, I would say on the ground, boots
on the ground.
So, you've heard me talk in the past
that we have to work hard in our yards
and our and work on how we can move our
our cars quicker and and meet our our
customers' expectations and we're doing
a very good job on the customer service
side, but we've recognized we've got to
get better operationally.
Our team's also very been very focused
on
uh what resources do we have? Do we have
uh too many locomotives? Cuz actually
too many locomotives, it sounds
counterintuitive, but can be a problem.
You're just not as one, you're not as
efficient. But the congestion and
everything comes with it. So, our team's
been very focused on that. And then, how
do we best use our employees? Well,
that's something our team's working hard
on,
but uh and we're working hard to become
more efficient, more effective. But we
also have to very much recognize where
we are versus our industry peers.
This is the six Class 1 railroads that
operate in the US, and we're one of
them.
And you can see that last year
we were fifth out of six.
And that's a reality of where we are,
but we're also getting better, and we
are going to get better.
We recognize that this performance is
with our our as I said, our our team's
have worked hard, but there's a lot of
room for improvement. Now, the good news
is if I look out in in 2025, and what we
have here is our operating margin.
So, the 34 and 1/2% you see for
Berkshire, that's the operating profit
uh that came back to to BNSF associated
with its underlying operations.
That operating margin
improved by 2 and 1/2% 250 basis points.
That's a very positive outcome,
obviously. And by the way, in fairness
to our team, that's our the work they've
been putting in. That was that on a
nominal basis, that was the largest
improvement across the uh our five
peers.
So, we're pleased with that,
but we know there's a lot of work to be
done. If you look at our first quarter
results,
happy to report that okay, we went from
fifth to fourth, but our team we be the
first to say there's a lot more to be
done.
And if you look at our
overall operating margin there, very
consistent with the result last year.
And the efficiency we've delivered is
being maintained and improved versus the
quarter versus
over the quarter of 2025.
So again,
um
we we see
a lot of opportunity here to continue to
get better, but
to achieve where say Union Pacific is as
a leader at with an operating margin of
39.5%,
we know that's going to require a step
change both as as how we're operating,
but even how we approach our operations.
An important step that we've or or
something we've identified,
we like to identify the gaps and where
we can get better, is technology.
And we're doing a lot at BNSF and I'll
touch on our other businesses
here when I go through technology, but
that's where we see a step change or or
potentially where our a few of our peers
have gapped out versus where how we're
using technology.
Uh
I'm going to back up to GEICO and then
I'll come back to BNSF.
Cuz it was approximately 4 years ago I
was in a GEICO meeting with our
management team there. And they were
discussing this price to to risk in
segmenting customers. And we had our
operational team from GEICO, they had
the commercial team, but they had the
tech team there.
And they're often there and and you're
looking for some help, but what I heard
in that discussion was a clear
technology transformation that was
happening at GEICO.
It was obvious that the technology was
going to be a big part of the solution
as GEICO tackled
uh their certain challenges."
And as our meeting wrapped up,
I very much wanted to spend more time
with the technology team uh to
understand what was what what was
driving this and and they were calling
it a technology transformation
cuz I could see that it was so
applicable to what we were going to do
what we needed to do and what we would
pursue across our non-insurance
businesses.
So so what is this technology
transformation that they described at
GEICO?
Uh
I'll I'll summarize it in a a few
different ways, but first and foremost,
we recognized we were going to become a
builder
of technology
rather than just a buyer of technology.
And that meant that instead of we had a
number of systems and we often bought
the related applications or software
that came with it. And yes, it's it's a
valued uh application, but it was
disconnected from all our systems,
obviously. We didn't have that ability
to then use the information, get to the
data. And what they started to talk
about is simplifying the infrastructure,
making sure we would build what we
needed ourselves and deliver solutions
back to our customers, and we would have
clear access to the data. All things
that make a lot of sense, but
a massive challenge and it doesn't
happen overnight and we're still on that
journey at at GEICO in year five.
There's no question. But,
quickly recognized that this could be
used across our other businesses. Very
fortunate that at GEICO they had put
their leadership team in place to drive
forward this transformation.
And the most senior leader
uh
then
uh came from GEICO, joined our
non-insurance operations, took on a
senior leadership role, the leadership
role helping us with the technology
transformation at uh BH Berkshire
Hathaway Energy,
and then also as the senior technology
officer at BNSF.
So, we started down that journey.
And one of the first things you have to
do is say, "Okay, we need a different
resource base." So, now we're hiring
engineers. We hire developers in our
technology group that help us start to
build the solutions we need for these
businesses. And and it's
going beyond Geico now.
Um
and we still have our valued employees
there and and and they may be retraining
or transitioning to other roles, but the
reality is we need less people managing
uh the applications and the software and
more people building outcomes that our
our businesses need.
Now, when I asked our team, "Well, how
does AI fit fit fit into this artificial
intelligence?"
Well, it's actually a big piece of this
cuz it's effectively what goes on top of
a lot of our systems. And that's what
they're building. They're using AI to
build applications. And that's all
great, but we also know there's certain
risks around humanity. There's risks and
and there's the broader risk for
globally and for the uh
and for our country.
But there's also risks within our
businesses. And as they just start
heading down this path, I said, "Well,
okay,
how should we think about this? How how
are we How should we all be comfortable
we're approaching this uh correctly?"
And they said, "Well, we don't really
like to call it artificial intelligence.
They call it narrow artificial
intelligence." And they have three
really important principles associated
with it.
And the first one was that, yes, we're
using it.
And we'll use it
with these engineers we have and and and
these highly skilled individuals we
brought in. But but how are we going to
manage it? Well, the first thing was
that we still have our employees, our
senior management team involved in
implementing the recommendations.
That we then receive associated with the
the architecture, the framework they put
in place. There may be in there may be
things that still occur and and should
occur just like they did within our
systems or within that. But as it as it
moves up and the important decisions are
being made, there's human involvement.
Our managers, our employees are
involved. And that's part of the
governance that's effectively in place.
The second piece is what they call the
safeguard.
And the safeguard is very intriguing
because
right away,
of course, we all want good governance.
We want that in place. But what's that
mean? And our team said, "Okay,
here's how I would describe it. If if we
ask for an outcome, we want a
recommendation or an action,
and we ask it now and then
half hour later, we ask, do we get the
exact do we get the exact same outcome?
If we can receive that same outcome,
we're we're it's effectively the
safeguard. We know we're utilizing that
application properly. And importantly,
it means we've got a defined data set
that we're comfortable with.
And and I like to call it the
constraint. We know we're constraining
our data. We know what data we're using
and we know what data is coming in.
Now, when you talk about all the
operations that were focused on,
yes, the next day of operations come in
and it updates that that that data set
and we may get a different if we ask the
question
the day later, we'll get a marginally
different answer. It's got new
information. But, if we ask it, well, if
you ignore today's information and just
focus on yesterday, do we get the same
answer? Yes. So, we we call that our
safeguard.
And then the third thing
on technology and associated with this
narrow AI is it has to be
um additive to our businesses. We're not
going to do AI for the sake of AI. You
can spend a lot of money in this area,
and we need to know what we're trying to
achieve,
and do we see a valued proposition uh
for the businesses. So, that's what we
call narrow AI. Um and if you see how
it's uh starting to be applied at BNSF,
it's incredible.
So,
if I think of BNSF,
um
uh we have
uh uh
uh the expansive network I touched on.
We have a variety of trains leaving from
a variety of points every day. I've
touched on it can be the intermodal
trains of 150 to 200 on our tracks a
day, which are moving very quickly and
often leaving LA to deliver product in
Chicago 48 hours later. Or it can be in
the last quarter, we had more than 750
trains a day moving across that system.
There's weather, uh there's equipment
failures.
We share our tracks, we allow Amtrak to
use them. They can be running on time or
they can be running behind schedule. We
have to adjust all to that. And the
reality is
Katie and her team been they they have a
a system that's been running for 177
years.
But,
we were not there in how we could use
technology to operate that better. And
that's what we're using or we've just
started down the path of uh that's how
we know we'll see that step change in in
our operating performance.
Now to summarize it all that, but I want
to let you know it's it's all around
operational excellence. We are going to
get better at rail, but we're going to
use that framework across all of our
businesses. They very much will create
the framework and then our teams can
embrace it if they so so choose and
we'll help them see the value of it, but
there is an opportunity there and
I'll break it down with one last comment
around technology.
Um when you think of a artificial
intelligence, everybody talks about the
large language models and
okay, they're learning models and
there's a lot more to it than
I just highlighted, but I summarize it
as one thing and this is why there's an
opportunity across all our businesses.
Those large language models, I really
communicate them and I communicate them
to our teams or at least it helps me
understand it. They're large logic
models. We're at this point in time,
we're using it to solve logical
challenges in our business and what
we're trying to do it is in a more
efficient fashion, I do it more quickly
and get to a better answer.
So, that was a lot in technology, but it
touches the whole franchise of of
Berkshire.
If I move to energy now
and provide an update there,
I'm just going to touch on the
opportunity first and then come to the
challenges cuz as I've just discussed
technology,
that's the opportunity in energy. One of
the core inputs to all those data
centers, hyperscalers associated with
artificial intelligence is energy. Our
businesses have that opportunity in
front of them.
At at Berkshire Hathaway Energy. Uh
And yes, we're pursuing them and and
we'll do it I'll touch on it in a in in
a way we view it's the right approach
for both our states and our customers.
But
I would highlight it's not new to us. If
you just go across the river a little
bit east Iowa,
we serve just under 50% of of that
state.
If you look at the number of data
centers and hyperscalers in that state
is it's very significant. We have four
very large hyperscalers data centers
there or or builders of them
and and ultimately the their customers
using it.
But if I look at our peak load, i.e. the
amount of energy being used from those
data centers,
it's at 8% of their peak load. And the
only reason I highlight that 8% is when
I hear people in the industry
and all the utilities around us a lot of
states, they're talking about this great
opportunity and jeez,
hopefully in the next 5 years they'll be
from a relatively starting point. They
want to get to the 5 to 10%.
And we're already at eight. And we see
opportunities to grow that by 50% over
the next 5 years or or potentially more.
But we'll do it in a way and you're
starting here more and more of this
across the US, we'll do it in a way
where
we're not going to impact the cost of
our other customers.
These users of the i.e. those the the
hyperscalers, the data centers,
and the users of the energy,
uh they have to bear their full cost. We
can't transfer that burden across all
our other customers. And and that's a
principle we've applied across all our
utilities and from the very early goings
when we're building these data centers.
And
I would highlight I think our team's
doing an exceptional job of that. If I
again go back to MidAmerican, if you
look at their with all the data centers
and hyperscalers and then in the
infrastructure they put in place,
their rates are still 45% below the
national average. That's just unheard
of. It's an exceptional outcome and it
just highlights they're doing the right
things when they build this
infrastructure or it's a part of it. And
we would highlight we have similar
positive outcomes across
uh the rest of our utilities. Now,
and I I would know one other thing, our
gas network or our infrastructure there,
our large pipeline company we have
there,
as they build out all this
infrastructure, not just in our
utilities, but across the US,
our pipeline footprint will grow. A lot
of it's being built by natural gas and
and we'll meet that challenge. But
here's an interesting point, 15% of the
gas consumed in the natural gas consumed
in the United States is touched by our
pipeline network or one of our our core
assets there. So, again, that's the
opportunity on the energy side.
Um but it's not without its challenges
and we've talked about this the past few
years.
Um and when I think of energy the
Berkshire Hathaway Energy Group, what's
the challenge? It's what I call the
regulatory compact.
We leave
your capital, our owner's capital,
Berkshire's capital in these businesses
and often a portion of the earnings that
they generate, we may reinvest back into
those businesses and for that we get a
very specific set of return.
And and it's a fair it's it's over the
long run it's been a very balanced and
fair return, but but how do you measure
that? It's versus the risks we take on
in that business and that's the compact.
Okay, you're going to pay us X% return
and what risks are you asking us to
take? And that
model has worked very good for a number
of years and and for centuries.
But the problem is it's becoming more
stressed.
If you think of inflation,
if you think of
the data center challenges, but I
strongly believe we're managing that
separately.
And then you move to assets that are 60
to 100 years old that are starting to
retire and we bring those into the
network. The challenge is every day to
get more efficient, more effective from
the operational side, but as a
regulator, as a governor, you're very
focused on I don't want my rates to go
up. I don't want to take on more risk.
They want to transfer that back to us.
And that's the regulatory compact and
unless that exists,
we do not if if we don't see that
balance, we don't deploy our capital
back into those businesses or into those
utilities. Said, and we work hard to
maintain it, but there's been a very
important challenge we've had within
that. We've touched on the past too. And
that's wildfires.
Wildfires in the west
uh very prevalent the last 50 15 plus
years in in California.
We experienced a very significant
wildfire in Oregon in 2020 or a number
of wildfires across Oregon, but we being
the state, but also the company. So,
there were a number of wildfires across
the state. We had certain equipment,
certain uh high winds, we had certain
failures with our equipment that
contributed to to those fires.
And associated with that, we fully
acknowledged where we there was
causation and where we were responsible
for it.
But,
there was also associated with some of
the fires and specifically one fire, a
class action lawsuit that was um had
very large
um
claims against uh our utility there
PacificCorp.
Um
And and we had to approach it such that
we'd resolve all the other matters, but
that was a class action and there was
specifically one fire that we strongly
felt we weren't responsible for. There
was zero causation.
There was an Oregon Forestry Department
report that said
the that PacificCorp did not contribute
uh nor cause the fire.
We took a very strong position there
that one we were not going to put more
capital in to fund the entity in these
type of uh risks and these type of
obligations. And secondly, we would
challenge that liability verdict.
And we challenged it. It's been a long
process.
But as owners and shareholders and this
was a very significant event that
occurred in this in this past quarter or
or occurred in in April. We're very uh
fortunate that it was up to the
appellate court. They reversed They
reversed and remanded that liability
verdict and said, "Back to ground zero.
Start over again." And what they were
really saying was that that class of
customers and who did we actually affect
and and and where was the causation?
That's been That will be revisited and
then the related damages.
Um
Some positive things associated with it.
We we recovered a billion dollars of
security we've already posted.
The people the the the the law firms
that pursued it are responsible for our
costs associated that period of time.
Not not our litigation costs, but the
the costs we incurred in posting the
bonds.
Uh so or posting that security. That's
$10 million or approaching likely $10
million. So, but the most important
thing is we've reset the stage there.
And that's very important because we're
working hard to get that regulatory
compact balanced.
And getting the right outcome. And we do
want to see these utilities move
forward. And we want to be a very good
operator and steward of those assets for
our our customers.
So the last thing I'll just touch on
wildfires.
So
when you think of Pacificorp, yes, we've
addressed that challenge. But to get the
right compact, we've worked with
Wyoming, Idaho. I've touched on Utah on
the stage to say it requires a judicial
system that supports the legislature,
the laws in place.
But more importantly, we all or as
importantly, we need good legislation
that then sets that that balance. We've
had it across those states and we'll
continue to work hardly work hard across
our our other states. So an exceptional
outcome and and wanted to make sure
you know, there's still a lot to be done
there cuz the we're back to the very
first uh
back to first base on the on the legal
proceedings.
Now moving to our manufacturing and
servicing businesses,
uh there's a the this highlights our
blues the manufacturing group that
represent represents approximately 70%
of that group. And the service and
retailing groups in the
in the gray or beige.
Uh
I like to think of When you think of our
manufacturing group, we've got three
groups there.
Uh we have our industrial group, we have
our our building products group, and we
have our consumer products. The consumer
products servicing and retailing as I've
touched on is now under Adam Johnson.
We're fortunate to have Adam as our
leader there.
He's managing 32 of those companies and
we'll have him on stage and we'll expand
on that more.
If I go back to those a few of those
core manufacturing groups, I'll start
with the industrial group.
And even when I think of the industrial
group,
I like to break it down into
uh a couple other groups,
but it's it's a good way to think of our
businesses and that's why I want to
share it. Within the industrial group,
we have a metals group that is very
strong.
There's three businesses.
We have Precision Castparts.
It's a business we acquired 10 years ago
in 2016.
It's run by Mark Donegan, who was the
CEO when we acquired the business, and
he continues to run it today.
And as owners and shareholders, we're
very fortunate to have Mark in that in
that position. He understands Precision
Castparts inside and out. He understands
the industry and very much works towards
delivering solutions for our our
customers.
The second important part of our metals
group is a business called IMC.
And they're our international, if you
can hear the management team over there,
a little uh international metal working
uh company. And
it's really interesting to see that
company. Well, one they make the tools
that removes
uh that removes steel.
So, they'll take a cylinder steel, they
create the tools, and then that gets
utilized in a variety of other
industries. It can be the aerospace,
uh like a Precision Castparts, and I'll
touch on that, or it can be another
industry like the auto.
If you think of what's happening in the
aerospace industry, and this is why
Precision Castparts and IMC has such
um a significant backlog or I'm
highlighting a backlog. If we look at
what Boeing just announced last quarter
or this quarter, but just recently,
their number of planes that they
delivered went up by
uh 11% quarter on quarter.
That's phenomenal, and they're talking
about even doing more. Very similar
results at Airbus. And that's who
Precision Cast Parts serves, and also uh
often IMC serves that industry. Um and
that's remarkable, but if you hear of
the backlog in that space,
it's 10 years.
And I I did ask our team the simple
question. I go, "Well,
is that many more people really flying?"
Like I get it, we're post-COVID and it's
building up, and I was sort of obviously
knew part of the answer, but it's really
remarkable why there that is at demand.
And
and a lot of us know this, but the
reality is to see what's driving it is
the efficiency of those planes and
engines is so great now that it's better
to buy the new plane and retire the old
the old plane. And what you have is this
10-year backlog that we're seeing a very
similar backlog across our our metal
businesses when you touch on our
Precision Cast Parts or or IMC. Now, the
third piece of the metal groups, and and
by the way,
uh I should just touch on this. Uh we
acquired
um IMC 10 year basic basically 10 years
before uh Precision Cast Parts. So, you
go back to a a 2006 timeline. We
acquired 80% of it. And again,
we're very fortunate to have the senior
leader there, Jacob Harpas, who
was at the business with the senior
leader running it back then and still
runs it today.
If I look at what how Precision Cast
Parts and and IMC works together,
Precision Cast Parts is now, if not
but very likely IMC's number one
customer.
We have them working on joint solutions.
Now move to that third group. In 2022 we
acquired Alleghany and we're fortunate
to have that in the family now and a and
a a very good addition.
But along came also with it came three
non-insurance businesses. There were a
variety of other ones there tucked into
the appropriate place in other
businesses. But one of them that is
standing that stood alone was WW Steel.
And it's a it was a family founded
company. It had transitioned to Rick
Cooper. He's he's here over in the
manager section. He's the CEO.
And it's a remarkable business. They
create basically they contribute uh
steel into a variety of core
infrastructures. It can be bridges. It
can be stadiums. It can be
arenas.
Their most famous one is the uh Las
Vegas Sphere.
And here we bought an an insurance
company and and Warren has touched on
this. We sort of had these nice add-ons
that I'm not sure we spent a lot of time
valuing that side of it, but
incredible additions to the Berkshire
family and
and that really comprises the the metals
group. Now if we move to the
second group is the chemical
group we have within the industrial
sector. We have three of those.
We have Lubrizol going back to 2011.
We've touched on that business many
times.
We then acquired OxyChem last year.
Uh associated with OxyChem, we announced
the acquisition. We closed it on January
2nd.
Very nice addition. Uh
I would say they they provide they
produce two core commodities. So it's
more a commodity chemical business.
And they're valued commodities in the
again industrial sector.
But their plants can't be replicated.
That would not be easy. So we've we've
got valuable assets.
And then the third piece of the chemical
group is a company called LSPI and
I'm just highlighting cuz it's a it's a
it's a real gem for for our owner
shareholders. But what it does is it it
creates a drag reduction agent that
allows oil to move through the through a
pipeline.
And you can imagine in the environment
we're in right now
with the with the the fundamental supply
and demand demand imbalance on oil, the
more oil that can be moved through those
pipelines and you can't quite double it,
but you can get darn close. They have an
amazing product and obviously in in very
high demand.
Now the last thing I'll just touch on
with the industrial group is we have
Marmon.
Excellent business.
And the reason that I'm touching on it
at the end it's it's really amazing cuz
it's the catchall.
It touches our rail industry
or the industry. It touches the energy
industry. It touches the metal industry.
It touches the chemical industry. It
touches on all the core industries in
the US and again a remarkable asset that
we have and and will continue to create
strong value for our owners and
shareholders. Now
the second piece of the manufacturing
group is our building products group.
I'm not going to go through all the
businesses in there cuz we have one that
is the bellwether and it tells you how
the rest of them are doing. That's
Clayton Homes.
The other businesses will their results
follow very much very closely that
because with Clayton Homes we're
building manufactured homes
or site-built homes. And there's a lot
that goes into it and
our other companies provide both
products to them and across that that
space. So it could be the insulation,
paint, carpet, a variety of other
things.
You look at Clayton's results, if you go
to the manufactured side of the
business,
our results are down
on on true homes manufactured and sold
down approximately 10%.
A little better than the industry
average, but that gives you a feel for
it. And
if you go to the site-built homes, we
were home builder, they're down around
5%, and the numbers I've been seeing for
the last quarter are probably more like
7% across the industry. Uh
and that and that's obviously driven by
where interest rates are and certain
other challenges for the uh for the
consumer.
But,
where's the opportunity
in in in in I'll touch on the challenge.
Where's the opportunity in these
businesses and and how is Clayton
tackling it? Um it's very much around
pursuing the American dream, and can we
help deliver that?
And what I what I have is a going to
have our team bring up a video a slide
that highlights this is actually a what
we call a cross-mod home. We have it in
the exhibit hall. It got moved in.
Had to cut the back off a little bit, so
it's not quite the
full size if you're if you're comparing
it to this. But, the reality is
um this is where the opportunity is is
within Clayton. We wanted to deliver on
the
an affordable home to the American
consumer.
This home you're looking at, we
Thank you.
And and thank you to our Clayton team.
Including the lot price, assuming it's
in the 40,000 range, and there's a lot
place in America where it's well below
that. We recognize some others uh it may
be greater, but we We deliver this home
on site, built two-bedroom
family home, living space, very very
beautiful living space for $249,000
delivered including the lot. That's
that's absolutely incredible. That's
delivering affordability to the
consumer.
Now, the CrossMod, how can we get it to
that price? 70% of that home is built in
our manufacturing side of our
facilities. So, those manufacturing
homes we produce, we now use it. The
last 30% is built by our site builders.
They bring the street appeal and all the
features that as a homeowner they may
want. So, it's a
exceptional product. Now,
we don't stop there. We still have a
very strong culture around the
manufactured homes. And and how how can
we get you know, what's the extreme on
that? Well, if we deliver a single and
this is a thousand square feet, if we
take it on to the manufacturing home and
think of a traditional manufactured
home,
and our team probably won't like it, but
it's more the the box, square box, but
what it does create is a home. It can be
a two-bedroom with a
again, very nice living space, very well
done.
Uh
now has a 30-year plus life on these
assets just like this one. They can get
a 30-year mortgage on the CrossMod or on
a manufactured home now. So, that's the
quality we're building it to. And we can
now do a single manufactured home uh
uh for just under $35,000.
We can deliver it. They still have to
get their lot or rent one,
but the reality is
we're creating homes that people can
afford and that's really where the
opportunity is is within Clayton. So,
very proud of what our team's doing
there.
Now, lastly, I'm going to move to the
service and and retailing business. I'm
not going to dive into it in our
consumer products business. Again, we'll
have Adam here. But, when I think of
those businesses and and Adam's been in
that role, as I said, so in since
December,
very much
um learning the businesses, getting to
know the management team.
Like myself and and and how we've always
done it, very will be very focused on
capital allocation and the risk and but
but also very focused on helping the
team achieve operational excellence
across those businesses.
Now, if you think of those businesses
across those 32 businesses, we have a
wide spectrum of where they are in their
life cycle. We have some that are still
growing and growing very quickly.
We have some that are growing at a much
smaller pace, but still
growing. And then we have some that I
would call in the more mature cycle, but
still creating a valued product to the
consumer customer,
and deploy and and creating capital
producing cash flows that often within
those businesses will redeploy across
our other businesses. And we'll have
that chance to discuss that with with
Adam.
Now, the last thing I just want to touch
on before we move to the second session
and I wrap up here. I'm going to move to
our balance sheet and and activity
associated with that.
In our first quarter of the of 2026,
we purchased $235 million of of
Berkshire stock.
Um you can see that reflected on the on
the slide.
Um
and we've talked about this often, but
when do we purchase stock? It's when our
intrinsic value,
again, conservatively determined,
exceeds the current price of our shares.
And we do that literally
um Warren and I will be discussing this
on a daily basis and and how do we feel
around the the overall value? It's not a
daily, but it we think about it daily.
And the reality is there's a lot of
different ways to to calculate intrinsic
value.
It could be a simple premium over book
value. You can take book value because
we have everything at a historical cost
basis and try to adjust our various
companies at
a BNSF is recorded on the books at the
original price we bought it at versus
what's it valued at today. You can go
through that exercise.
Or if I think of it more as how we would
think of businesses when we buy a stock
or a full company,
we think of it as we have our balance
sheet,
we know what our cash is, we know what
our US Treasuries are, we know what our
equity investments are.
They're marked to market.
And then we have our operating companies
in place.
And that's where we have to think about
what are the long-term economic
prospects of those businesses 5 years,
10 years from now. And then the other
important part of that equation is how
do we redeploy that capital
that comes off of it. And that's really
the the approach we take to the
intrinsic value.
Now, let's move to our balance sheet.
Uh the the the very specific numbers.
Um there's a lot of numbers here. Again,
I'll touch on a few captions.
If you look at our cash and US Treasury
bills,
there's a risk that people use the 397.4
billion as the headline number.
Cuz that is our cash and US Treasury
sitting there at the end of March.
However,
and we don't like these type of
adjustments, but it is important to
communicate it, there is 17.2 billion of
payables associated with the treasuries
that are in that total. How does that
happen? We bought the treasuries right
before the end of March.
And the payable, I eat the the the the
fact we use our cash
to purchase those treasuries, that that
occurred right after the end of March.
So, we've got the treasuries up in the
397, and we're still holding the cash.
Accordingly, our cash in US Treasury
bills net is 380 billion.
Um and yes, it it grew by that $7
billion you can see on the slide.
The other important thing to focus on is
our cash and investments at the bottom.
The 705.8
billion versus the 708.7
billion at the end of the year.
So, we're down just
uh under 3 billion.
Now, what what drives that or what
what's the underlying numbers behind
that?
We produced
uh a little more than uh well, close to
10.5 billion dollars of income and
related cash flows in in the first
quarter.
We also
uh
would have incurred certain capital
expenditures against our businesses.
We incur those to either
reduce risk in the businesses, to manage
those businesses on a sustainable basis,
or to pursue growth.
That was, like I said, just under 5
billion.
Again, we we are involved in our
management teams as they decide to
deploy that capital, and very
comfortable with that. And then the
other piece of the equation in the first
quarter was we closed on the Oxy
transaction. $9.5 billion
flowed out associated with that. Very
pleased with that.
Now, we did have two transactions last
year that we announced. Oxy Chem, we
announced it
and closed on it in this year. Last year
we announced Bell Labs, a smaller
transaction. We're fortunate to have it
join our company, Steve Leavy and uh
uh his team.
Um
great group there. So, our uh
Warren likes to say we finally delivered
uh
on on Charlie's objective around uh
we have a rat poison company that uh
we we we value highly, but it's an
exceptional business. But, the reality
is that's not in that number. We had the
Oxy transaction
resulted in a little more than a $3
billion
decrease in our our results. So, with
that, uh a very fullsome business
update, so I appreciate uh
the opportunities share where our
businesses are and where they're going.
So, thank you.
Now, I'm very excited to I'm going very
shortly have Ajit join us on stage uh
and we'll we'll move to the Q&A, but as
we as we transition to that session,
we'll have the GEICO video narrated by
Nancy. Thank you.
>> GEICO was started out um 90 years ago by
trying to make things simple and giving
a great price and service to customers.
And when you think about it, today is um
exactly the same thing. We're just
continuing to try and perfect that and
make it a little better every day, a
little faster, a little easier. I'm
Nancy Pierce, and I became CEO of GEICO
in December of of
Um prior to that, I was the chief
operating officer, but I have just had
my 40th anniversary with GEICO. I
started as a claims associate in 1986
right out of college, and I've just had
the pleasure over many, many years of
working in I think just about every
department or every sector um that GEICO
has. So, while I started in claims, uh
I've been in pricing, I've been in
product management, I've been in
underwriting. I've had an opportunity to
run operations in different parts of the
country. Um, but what really has kept me
all these years and what has inspired me
and I think inspires all 30,000 people
at GEICO is every day um we're
delivering for customers and um we're
doing something for them. We're saving
them money on a product that um you
know, everybody has to have, but maybe
you don't um necessarily want to use it.
Um, but when you do need to use it,
that's really the moment of truth. And
for us to be able to do that um and to
do it in a way that saves people money
and gives that outstanding um customer
service, that's what excites me every
day um and the reason that uh we have
customers and we'll continue to grow is
just keeping that as our North Star. And
if we do that, I think GEICO will be
very successful over the next 20 years.
GEICO was founded in 1936 by Leo and
Lillian Goodwin. And their idea was to
come direct to consumers and to cut out
the middleman and to have much better
cost and much better service for those
customers. So, in 1951, um Benjamin
Graham um took an investment in GEICO
and of course one of his students was
Warren Buffett. And that's when Warren
really started to think about GEICO and
to um deeply try and figure out what we
were doing and met with the leadership
of GEICO and that was one of his first
very big investments, um his personal
investments. And then later um he
started investing Berkshire Hathaway
shares. Um, and by 1996, he owned all of
GEICO.
From that beginning, we now insure
millions of cars, trucks, RVs, campers,
etc. We're in all 50 states
and we try and be there wherever the
customer needs us. That's always been
sort of number one. I think from the
first time I met Warren or Greg or Ajit,
they always start by talking about
integrity and reputation and making sure
that you're doing the right thing for
customers. So, it's something we live
and breathe every day at GEICO and it's
just it's absolutely a big big part of
our culture. Obviously, Berkshire
Hathaway was founded in in some ways on
insurance and being wholly owned is just
been terrific for GEICO and terrific for
our
customers over the years because it
really allows us to invest in our
business and to make long-term
decisions, not quarterly or annual
decisions on
what's best for growing our business.
And you know, obviously Berkshire has
many other insurance companies besides
GEICO and we do work together with them.
GEICO sells many of their products
you know, today and we continue to look
and bring more of them on to the GEICO
platform.
There always cycles in insurance.
Sometimes there's bad weather. It's just
making sure that the company's prepared
for all those things and to deliver on
that promise that we make to customers
when they buy that policy and to be
there in their hour of need. So, we take
that very very seriously. If you're
involved in an in an auto accident,
the last thing you want is to go weeks
and weeks and weeks before you get paid
and before the whole thing is resolved.
So, we really strive to do that now in
minutes where possible as opposed in
days or hours. Nobody really wants to
spend a lot of time with their insurance
company, but when they do, we want to
make sure that they're getting the very
best service as fast as they possibly
can. So, when I think about innovation,
it's really about things that are going
to allow us to handle claims faster Um
than anybody else in the industry. What
I'm really focused on is our customer
loyalty and retention. So, we want to
improve those. It's a very competitive
market right now.
You know, everybody has come out of sort
of a an unusual period out of COVID in
regards to frequency and severity.
So, I think everybody now, all of our
competitors are in the mode to try and
grow. And the best way for us to grow is
to retain, you know, every one of our
customers.
I think that what I'd like to
communicate is just that every day
30,000 people GEICO go to work in
support of millions and millions of
customers. And I want you to know that
that's what the GEICO team is delivering
for Berkshire day in and day out
is a reputation of doing the right
thing, saving customers money, and just
giving outstanding service.
>> Thank you, Nancy. And to the GEICO team,
thank you. We've got uh
uh
an exceptional leader in Nancy. And
again, appreciate taking on that that
senior role. Welcome, Ajit.
Uh
Yes.
Great to be up Great to be up here
together.
Ajit, if you don't mind, I'll start with
I touched on Tokyo Marine, an
exceptional transaction, exceptional
relationship. I know you've built over
many years with the Tokyo Marine
management team. But if you could just
expand on that strategic transaction and
relationship, we'll
love to start with that.
>> Sure. Thank you.
Uh
Tokyo Marine and Fire is the largest
non-life insurance company Excuse me,
insurance company in Japan.
They've been doing business for more
than 100 odd years and are clearly
regarded as a blue-chip company in the
international arena altogether.
They're clearly number one in Japan.
Every
Every insurance company would like to be
associated with them. They have a very,
very high reputation in Japan and
globally as well.
We, being in the insurance business for
the last
God knows how many years, we've tried
year after year to try and get a
relationship going with Tokyo Marine and
Fire.
It has not been easy because one of the
things we bring to the business is a
capital partner.
And Tokyo Marine
were cash-rich and they really never
needed capital in a big way.
They have been expanding in Japan. Now,
given the limited growth in Japan,
they've looked overseas and over these
last 8-10 years, they've really got most
of the low-hanging fruit overseas that
they would like to get.
Nevertheless, they are
keen and they are hungry for business
elsewhere outside Japan. And last year
we got a chance to spend some time with
them and talk to them in very general
terms about what the two of us could be
doing and should be doing with each
other.
After that initial conversation, which
probably took place nearly a year ago,
things moved fairly quickly.
So, to to sort of get get to the bottom
line,
in March, we finally announced a
transaction with them.
That transaction has three legs to it.
Uh I'll describe to you each one of them
and that'll give you an idea of
uh what the relationship is right now
and we've got a long way to go, of
course. Uh firstly, we bought some stock
in the company. Just a simple
transaction. We wrote a check for 1.8
billion US dollars and we got 2 and 1/2%
of the stock of Tokyo Marine and Fire.
That was one part of the transaction.
Secondly, they have a good and
profitable book of business in terms of
what they write in Japan and elsewhere.
We
took a piece of the business, just that
property casualty business that they
write. And you know, we compensated them
for their efforts in getting the
business, originating the business, and
running the business. But we get a slice
of their business got no for several
years down the road.
And the third piece was
a sort of strategic agreement between
the two of us.
Uh it is not spelled out in a lot of
detail. Uh and normally I would be very,
very concerned about having open-ended
strategic
uh
transactions. But Tokyo Marine
they are a quality company. In fact,
they remind me of uh
the the uh phrase that J.P. Morgan used,
I don't know how many years ago,
doing business in a doing first-class
business in a first-class way.
And that is Tokyo Marine in the
insurance industry.
We have a general statement that we'll
work with each other, we'll coordinate
when it comes to
finding opportunities elsewhere, running
businesses operationally, and that is
something that'll evolve over time in
terms of who's going to bring what to
the party and I certainly hope this
serves as a springboard for both of us
to move on to the next plateau.
>> Thank Thank you, Ajit.
An exceptional transaction and a real
long-term relationship. Thank you so
much and
you know, it's one thing when I think of
our also it reminds me of our five other
Japanese companies that we've made
investments in. Yes, we like the
financial investment, but we also see
long-term strategic relationships that
can develop across one or all five of
them. So, fully support and excited by
everything you just described, Ajit.
Thank you.
Now, we'll move to the more formal not
the formal, but our traditional Q&A,
question and answer. And we'll go again
to the stations and to Becky, but today
we'll start with station one. Station
one?
>> Hi, my name is
Warren
from Omaha.
I've recently undergone a let's call it
a significant change in role.
And I have
well, let's just say a not insignificant
portion of my net worth tied up in
Berkshire stock.
Now, Greg,
I've been watching this company for a
while.
A long a very long time and and
I've been telling people that I have no
intention of selling a single share.
Not one.
So, my question is a simple one. I'm 95
years old. I've got nothing but time and
cherry Coke and I want to know,
just so I have something to tell my
fellow shareholders,
why should they hold their Berkshire
shares for the long term?
>> Anyway, Greg
I'll let you take it from here.
>> Well, uh
Well,
Warren from Omaha
Very astute question.
Um
Uh
If if
If I think of what we've already
discussed this morning, which is our
culture and values and highlighted
that's the bedrock of Berkshire.
Then what did it create? It created the
foundation that we have today.
And that's this this incredible set of
assets that exist within within
Berkshire.
We have
uh our insurance business uh led by Ajit
and and his team. And we've talked about
the the it being the heart
with talent and opportunities cuz we
have capital
uh available and it'll be available at
different times. So, we've got
significant opportunities there.
If I think of our
uh our non-insurance businesses, I I
spent a lot a lot of time on those, but
we've got unique opportunities on the on
the operational excellence side and
we'll pursue them and they'll be
incremental investment opportunities in
there.
Uh
we have our equity investments
as we know and we also have a very
important asset.
We have our cash and US Treasuries.
And
it it serves a couple purposes.
One
uh and you've heard
Warren and Charlie say this before, I've
said it. We do not intend to be beholden
to anyone. We start with that position.
Thank you.
And it's how we manage Berkshire and
we'll continue to manage Berkshire. Now,
that asset, the cash and treasuries,
also creates a unique opportunity.
Um it creates the opportunity to deploy
it across these different groups.
It can be
uh and and and it will be dependent upon
the opportunity, i.e., the is there is
it a strong value proposition? But if it
presents itself,
we'll be prepared to act decisively and
with and with significant capital.
That's what that's what it's there for.
Um
and we have
uh well, we will and and and do have
opportunities on the within the equity
investments that we uh we currently have
and and beyond that.
We have our operating businesses, as I
said, and our and our and and there it
can be
deploying capital back into those
businesses, as I touched on the capital
expenditure side, or it can be the
incremental opportunity to acquire 100%
of of a business.
And then there's the opp- opportunities
that Ajit's already alluded to on the
uh insurance side.
But what's the other unique thing is
uh yes, Berkshire's a conglomerate
and we recognize that, but we are unique
conglomerate in that we can move our
capital
very efficiently, and that's the value
of the the conglomerates. We can move
our capital very efficiently across each
of those groups. We can move it from
insurance to non-insurance into
equities, or if we so choose to hold it
in cash or back across those in a very
efficient way and a very tax-efficient
way. I would also add to the fact that
um
uh
how are we unique as a conglomerate? We
live by the fact that we We bureaucracy.
We do not embrace and and and and our
Thank you. Yes.
Ajit is the biggest fan. He reminds me
constantly. I love it. I treasure it.
But no, we we've heard many times the
ABCs, the arrogance, bureaucracy,
complacency that can creep into a
company will kill a company, and we
intend to uh
never allow that to happen. So, we have
this unique opportunity to both
take the businesses we have today, take
that foundation, and build upon it.
We also have that capital to be deployed
back into them.
How will
personally myself and the team define
success?
We'll define success is
can we ensure that Berkshire endures in
its current form?
That means we do business as we do
today, consistent with the cultures,
values, business principles we have,
with the with the long-term objective in
and with great purpose and intent,
create long-term value for our
shareholders.
That will define success.
>> Anyway, Greg,
I'll let you take it from here. I've got
a few things on my plate. Actually,
excuse me, I'm going to take this.
Someone may want to sell me their
business.
I hope it's an elephant.
>> Well, yeah.
Now,
as you as you've all picked up, that was
a that was a deep fake. Uh
But but here's the interesting thing.
That was That was done with zero input
from Warren's voice, photo, you know, we
we got we were able to obtain that with
uh information that's out there and
replicate those actions and that voice.
And the reality is that's what we're
dealing with when we think of Berkshire
and how we have to protect it every day.
It can go to deep fakes and they're
using a way to try to penetrate our
business. It can be the cyber attacks.
But it's a good it's a great reminder
for our team because that is a
significant risk across Berkshire that
we're managing every day. Cyber risk.
And it's one that we take extremely
serious. I touched on the technology
side. We're constantly using technology
to uh
protect
our businesses. And then we're also
trying to use technology to identify it.
We've all We're a lot of us have heard
about mythos and what's going on there.
Um we're we're we're very focused on
those risks. But
as you before we move truly to our first
question, um
and you've touched on this many times.
When you When we think of cyber risk and
we ensure it,
what's what's our current approach
across our insurance businesses and your
thoughts there?
>> Okay. Um
so cyber
is something we worry about in the
insurance operation at two levels.
Firstly,
there is a huge demand
by people in business all over the world
who are interested in buying protection
against some kind of a cyber incident.
Uh
we have been slow in terms of
consciously, we have been slow in terms
of entering that class of business as an
underwriter.
Uh the reason for that is
firstly, on cyber, I find it very
difficult to have some meaningful method
to assess and model the aggregation.
Uh
people will tell you we've got it under
control and they'll show you all kinds
of models, but nothing that I can really
hang my hat on in terms of we really
have a good feeling for what the
aggregate exposure is because any risk
we take on, the first question we ask
ourselves how bad can bad be?
And I'm not sure we can answer that
question
as well as we should.
So,
the second reason is cyber has been a
very popular fashionable product in
these last several years.
We have not played in it. Now, as it
turns out, they haven't been very many
cyber losses.
So, people who've taken on cyber risk
have actually made profits and as a
result of which the premiums that cyber
insurance commands has been coming down
over time.
So, we hate entering a line of business
where prices are coming down. So, we're
sort of sitting on the sidelines and
I'm not sure when, but I'm pretty
certain that the day will come when we
will have a fairly significant role to
play in cyber.
Uh
secondly,
you know, we being a large company
uh exposed to cyber perils ourselves.
We try and do the best we can.
We I think I as good as anyone else.
Now, cyber insurance is very highly
regulated by the regulators and we've
been consistently
above what the regulations call for.
So, I think we're doing the best we can,
but I cannot be categorical about it.
>> Thank you, Ajit.
Let's go to the now truly the Q&A
session.
Uh
Becky, we'll start with with you and
thank you for being so patient. Thank
you.
>> Thanks, Greg. This first question, Ajit,
let's follow up with the AI. This is
slightly different though. This comes
from Billy DeRoss in Ardsley, New York
who writes, "In an era of increasingly
complex risk models and AI tools, where
does human judgment still provide
Berkshire a competitive advantage?"
>> Uh okay.
Uh Becky, just repeat the last part of
the question.
>> Yeah,
where is human judgment still a
competitive advantage for Berkshire when
you consider AI tools that are out
there?
>> Yeah.
So, AI also is very fashionable right
now.
Uh
people are jumping into it in the from
the insurance space and from the
non-insurance space.
And clearly, if AI becomes
reality as is being projected, then
there's no question about it. It'll be a
huge game changer.
Right now, what we are seeing is AI
being used as a productivity tool, as a
mechanism for reducing
uh labor costs, and
and
doing routine repetitive things.
I do not think AI will reach a point
where you can make a trade-off on things
like pricing, settling a claim. Uh
that is still years away, and
you know, I tend to be skeptical. I'll
be surprised if AI can solve that
problem for you.
Uh so, if you're counting on
AI telling you which stock to buy and
which one to sell, I don't think that's
going to happen.
>> Ajit, I I I found it interesting. Ajit
and I were together
a few weeks ago, and Ajit got his
team on the phone cuz we're discussing
this exact question, Becky. And
as you your team immediately went to
yes, the cyber risk, which we've already
touched on. They then went quickly to
the fact that really across the
insurance businesses,
and it's that building concept that
we're very focused on
how do we become more efficient in in
creating code and managing it. They they
immediately went to that aspect of it.
And then as you touched on
becoming more productive, more
efficient, and and they went as far to
say I thought the example was really
good. I mean, if if we were looking at a
risk and we had our traditionally
traditional underwriters doing it, we
might have looked at the five largest
risks.
And your team highlighted that now we
can pretty much in a fairly quick way,
yes, we focus on those, but we'll get a
very quick view on another using
technology. We'll probably look at those
other 15 risks and have a strong view on
it. Is that fair?
>> Yep, that's it. Exactly.
>> So, using it within the businesses but
well aware it's evolving, I think is a
fair way.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
So.
Thank you. Thanks, Ajit.
>> Thank you.
>> Now, formally station one. Unless one of
you're up there again.
>> Hi everyone. My name is Lavia and I'm
from Irvine, California, born in
Kunming, China.
And I really want to say it's my honor
to see both Mr. Buffett and Mr. Abel
today.
I really want to say Mr. Buffett, your
speech has helped me get through many
many dark moments in my life and stand
back up, not only in investment. I
really appreciate you.
Okay, my question is as a young investor
navigating both uncertainty D rapid
technology change. I often struggle to
balance patience with action. How would
you personally distinguish between the
two, please?
>> Sure.
Um I think I think
our one of our greatest strengths at
Berkshire is patience
and being disciplined when it comes to
allocating our capital.
They'll There will be opportunities
that come over time and and for
yourself. And it doesn't mean there's
not opportunities now,
but it doesn't mean you need to uh
deploy all your capital or or spend all
your money right now. And that's really
our approach. We take every day and we
we recognize we've got a a significant
asset in in our cash and US Treasuries
using it as our ourselves as an example.
And I would think of uh the cash you're
holding is that. And And that's an
asset. It's a great opportunity. You'll
You'll You'll feel the moment or or or
feel there's a a strong value
proposition with an opportunity.
When do we see those? We We've aligned
our investment philosophies, which is
one, we very much have to understand
what we're investing in. So, we want to
have a strong It can be You touched on
technology and the things you're seeing
there in the evolution and how fast it's
all changing.
Um
I always start with and I know we always
have at Berkshire, do we understand this
business? Do we understand the
opportunity? And more importantly, do we
understand the risk?
Then we want to have a very
uh understandable view of what the
economic prospects look like for the
next 5 10 years. Not Not Yes, the next
year matters, but we're not in that
investment for a year. It has to be a
long-term view of where that uh where
that opportunity will go. We take it one
piece one step further. We're going to
be in these investments forever. So, we
think that way and we need to we we like
to have a strong view on the management
team that they're they're capable and
operate with with high integrity. And if
if we can get to that
position,
but the most important being then at the
end, the value has to work for us to
deploy our capital.
We're we're not anxious to just deploy
capital into subpar opportunities. We
want to know it meets our principles and
then we'll as I said earlier earlier,
we'll act decisively both quickly and
with significant capital.
Ajit, anything you'd like to
>> No.
>> Thank you.
Becky.
>> Oh, uh
This question is
for Greg
and it comes from Mark Lander in Miami
who says he's been a Berkshire
shareholder for 30 years. He said,
"Greg, given your background as a
business operator which differs from
Warren's roots as a public market
investor, could you share how you
balance your time between overseeing the
wholly-owned subsidiaries and the $288
billion now equity portfolio? Also, does
your operator lens change how you
evaluate new investment opportunities
compared to Warren's historical
approach?"
Thank you, Becky.
So, obviously, yes,
the the many years of operating a
variety Berkshire Hathaway Energy and
then in the role of the um
uh, chairman of of non-insurance
operations. Fortunately, I was
Ajit and I were in those co-roles for
for the past 8 years, 9 years now. But,
that created a
very significant opportunity to for
myself personally to understand those
businesses.
And as I've already touched on, we have
exceptional
businesses, exceptional leadership
there.
But, there are still opportunities
there. But, but it does
does I'll spend a certain amount of time
associated with those businesses and and
make sure we're allocating our capital
properly and we're still uh, thinking
about risk across those businesses
and encouraging operational excellence
cuz
listen, having been inside a business
uh, it's easy to look at your internal
metrics and convince yourself you're
doing okay.
And you have to look outside and say,
"Well, what is the customer seeing,
feeling?
Uh, what are our competitors doing?" And
I think that's what we can bring on the
operational side. I've touched on
bringing uh,
uh, Adam on or or him taking on the
incremental role across 32 businesses.
He'll bring that great operating
knowledge and we have Ajit on the uh,
insurance side.
Now, when it comes to the equity
portfolio and again, allocating time,
um, still we have significant
opportunities there
uh, as we look at deploying our capital
that that's on the balance sheet and I I
shared where our uh,
our cash and and and US treasuries were.
Um,
I would highlight,
if you think of as it as it exists
today,
I articulated this in the letter. It
it's in a it's in a very
uh, we have a concentrated portfolio.
And we highlighted that by calling it
across the core but it's what the best
name is really a concentrated portfolio
of investments.
And we had our our core four you and you
concentrated investments I highlighted
in um
uh in the letter.
We have our Japanese
investments
and it's interesting if you then go to
the next number of companies where we
have
positions that are very significant.
Uh
and I would add that um
uh
associated with those there we may still
be acquiring shares or or rationalizing
what's the right position across that
portfolio. So the first group
when I highlighted it was just under 200
billion and and remains at that. We have
and it's closer to 100 and say 85
billion right now.
You then add in associated with B at the
other investments we have a a B of A, a
Chevron, a Google, companies like that.
Um
there's another 70 billion dollars of
investments.
And and what that highlights is a very
significant portion of our total
investments are highly concentrated and
sit across a limited portfolio.
That the the active management of that
is really limited. Is really what I'm
what I'm highlighting. We know those
businesses well. We know the management
teams. Those are the things that Warren
and I would still be absolutely
collaborating on and discussing.
You don't have to discuss them every day
but if there's something going on across
those businesses we'd be discussing it
that week or that month. Um and maybe
it's where they're going or what we've
we've learned. The Japanese companies
just announced their results uh
in the last 48 hours and that was a an
active conversation and I that Warren
and I had just around the results in the
businesses and what we're seeing there
yesterday morning. So that that's those
are core but it doesn't mean we just set
them aside or they're concentrated
investments. We're constantly aware of
them and evaluating them. Ted
Ted manages another 20 billion or just
under 20 billion of our our capital and
and his responsibilities go far beyond
that. He obviously helps us across a
variety of our
opportunities or
helping us assess risk or capital
deployment in our in our businesses. So
we're fortunate have that.
But it's a it's a portfolio that's very
manageable when you think of that the
management around it and the and what's
required of it.
The the as as we've touched already is
the opportunity to deploy that cash in
US Treasuries
at the right time
is a very significant opportunity
including equities, including what we
may see on our
on our within the operating businesses
and including the the insurance side.
But um
um so when it comes to allocating the
time
uh yes, there's a certain amount of time
spent on operations and and we'll
prioritize that cuz we see a huge
opportunity to continue to uh
uh improve and close those gaps and and
operational excellence. We see
opportunities within our existing
portfolio but that's that is either
adding to them or or right-sizing it and
then constantly evaluating what other
opportunities are out there either in
whole totality acquiring a company
that's private or public.
Equally looking at what are the
incremental opportunities if we're going
to own a piece of a company and and
those are evaluated in the same fashion.
I mean, we look at as I said the
economics and and really tied to that
the the last answer.
Ajit, any thoughts there?
>> Yeah. Uh
I really think
capital allocation and operating
businesses
are two sides of the same coin.
And
a comment that Warren had made several
years ago, I think goes a long way.
When he made the comment saying that a
good capital allocator will make a good
operating manager and vice versa.
>> Well said, Ajit.
>> I didn't say it didn't work.
It worked.
>> Well said, Warren.
No.
But obviously we recognize it and it the
last thing I just say around that and I
would I mean, when you think of our
operating companies and I touched on
this, we have a very deep bench. We have
exceptional operators that understand
their business. They understand their
industry, their customers. Yes, do we
have still have opportunities to get
better? Yeah, it's continuous
improvement and we'll close those gaps,
but we have exceptional teams there. And
be it myself, Adam, Ajit, we spend our
time making sure we're comfortable how
the capital is allocated. We understand
the risk. And then are we aware of those
gaps? So, thank you, Becky.
Let's move to station two.
>> My name is Jackie Han from China,
currently working in Toronto, Canada.
This is my ninth Berkshire meeting.
So, I guess I'm officially a repeat
customer. And like the most
shareholders, I plan to stick around for
the long term. Over the years, Mr.
Buffett has often said that capital
allocation is Berkshire's most important
responsibility. Today, we are in a very
different environment. Interest rates
are higher, cash actually earns
something again, and competition for
quality assets has increased globally.
Uh the station lady actually read my
mind a little bit. Actually, my question
is how should long-term investor think
about their capital allocation approach
today when patience has a real
opportunity cost? And also for Mr. Abel,
as you step further into this role, how
do you personally balance patience
versus action, especially when standards
are shaped by the track
of Mr. Buffett's track record? Thank
you.
>> Thank you. And thank you for attending
your ninth shareholder meeting.
Yeah, so
again, when it comes to our capital
allocation approach and and the in the
long-term
uh
approach we've taken,
it's very much aligned with our owners
and our shareholders that are here.
Uh
they've taken a very long-term approach
around their their investment. They've
We were fortunate to have this unique
ownership base within our our
shareholdings.
And again, over the long-term, there
will be significant opportunities for
Berkshire.
And and this is where it's back to the
patience and the discipline around
capital allocation.
Do we have any idea what
uh will occur tomorrow or will that
event be 3 years from now,
2 years from now? But there will be
dislocations in markets that again will
allow us to act, and that's where the
both disciplined approach, knowing how
we're going to
uh our investment philosophy around
uh those activities.
A- And I would add, it's not that we
don't see exceptional companies out
there today
that we'd love to own a at I'll be
careful cuz I I wouldn't want to say we
we long-term we'd be happy on those
companies because there there's
excellent companies that have excellent
management teams that that
we evaluate and I would say when you
think of the world that doesn't mean
there's multiple handfuls of those type
of companies but they're there.
But the price
relative to the opportunity, the
economic prospects of that company and
the related risks
um we're not interested in in acquiring
those those companies at that at that
price.
And that can be a piece of them or all
of them. That that doesn't mean that
opportunity won't be there
in the future. It's what we spend our
time preparing for.
Uh I e. One being disciplined but two
being aware of of some core
opportunities we would treasure or value
at the right price.
And and that really ties back to the
to the to the discipline.
And I you asked me personally
uh
my plan for for patience for over maybe
quote action.
Again, it aligns to
uh I took this role and and I'm so
fortunate being in work with Ajit and
others but we do it because we we love
and believe in Berkshire. Warren brought
this great commitment to to Berkshire
a a great understanding of Berkshire and
passion.
And and with that he wanted to create
something that was very long-term
including the opportunities it would it
would create. Uh
Personally, and I know all of us we
bring that that same passion.
And we
fully intend to do it consistent with
how we've uh
how we've done it in the past. So, thank
you.
Yeah, yeah, Ajit, please. I should have
Thank you.
>> Uh,
you know,
insurance, much like investing,
is a game that requires patience.
And
it is very difficult to get people to
sit back and do nothing.
When I recruit people,
my modus operandi, I tell them right up
front. I said I tell them, "Your job is
to say no.
You will get bombarded with deals
day in and day out,
but your base case is just say no.
I said, "Every now and then, you will
come across a deal that will hit you
with a 2x4, and it'll be screaming
money.
That's when you come to me, and we'll
then make a decision whether to do it or
not."
You know, all all kidding aside, it is
very difficult
to sit there and do nothing while
everyone else is being wined and dined
by brokers and taken to London. Uh,
but I think the real test of being
successful, certainly in insurance and
therefore in investing as well, is the
ability to say no.
>> Yes. Well said, Ajit.
I think it applies to insurance, and I
think your earlier comment, yeah, I
mean, it is it's so applicable across
all our businesses.
I I That so they did remind me of one
story, and I'll just share it quickly.
We, uh,
we were we'd acquired a company, and we
were still in, um,
having a challenging matter with how
we're going to resolve some matters, and
I remember the the deposition, and I
don't want to say it's one of my most
proudest moments, but it was close to
it. They said, "Well, how would you
describe Greg as a as a CEO and a
manager?" And they said, "Well, all he
says is no."
And I think that's part of management.
You have to be ready and including
investment, you have to be disciplined
and ready to say no. And and trust me
I we understand that a lot of people
have this urgency to have, but Ajit, you
described it uh
incredibly well.
Thank you.
Let's go back to Becky.
>> Thanks, Greg. Uh this question is for
Ajit and um the writer is Mindy
Wasserman.
The question is, "How and when can you
offer insurance to ships crossing the
Strait of Hormuz?"
>> I mean, the short answer is depends on
the price.
>> Ajit, I uh
I like your Charlie answer.
Um obviously some thought has gone into
that because there's a lot of dynamics
there.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of chatter.
There's a lot of need. Uh
Fortunately, there's enough capacity in
the insurance world today that would
like to
write that risk for no other reason, but
people are sitting on excess capital and
they'd like to find a way to deploy that
excess capital.
Uh we ourselves have taken uh small
participation
in a program that's put in being put in
place so as to write insurance for the
ships in the in the Strait of Hormuz.
We haven't written any deals as yet.
It's still being fine-tuned, but if we
can get our terms in terms of the
underwriting decisions and the fact that
the US Navy will escort these ships, we
have put a price on which we will be
comfortable underwriting that risk, but
nothing's happened as yet.
>> Thank you. Thanks, CG. Thanks, Becky. Uh
station three.
>> Good morning, Mr. Abel.
My name is Joshua
and I'm from China.
So, my question is about the key
investing principle, staying within your
circle of competence.
I imagine you and Mr. Buffett each have
a somewhat different circle of
competence. So, how do you plan to
manage the portfolio by established by
Warren Buffett? Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Um
Yeah, as far as managing the existing
portfolio
and what's in that,
um
that portfolio, as you as you touched
on, was put together by put together by
Warren,
but it is a group of companies that
Warren understands
uh
thoroughly and I would
be very comfortable that I understand
the businesses, the economic prospects
of those businesses. So, and that's why
when I outlined it in the letter, I was
really trying to send the message that
yes, we're very comfortable with those.
We understand it and and yes, it's a
concentrated portfolio, but
you know, their businesses will evolve
and there's there's risks that may
surface, so we're we'll constantly
evaluate it, but it's it's it's a
portfolio
very, very comfortable with. And, you
know, Warren Warren touched on
Tim's Tim Cook's uh
um amazing success with Apple, but it
you know, Warren and and and Tim were
recently discussing this and and they
were talking about well, Warren didn't
invest in it because he saw it as a a
technology stock. He saw what the
product was and how much the individual
consumer valued it. And, it's a
remarkable perspective, but it would be
very much a similar perspective that I
think many of us would apply. Would you
know uh
maybe electricity I know a lot I know
how to make sure something gets
generated and how we're going to
transfer and all that, but am I really
that interested in how they make the
Apple phone? I I'll be intrigued by
where they make it and some of the risks
and challenges around that, but I I do
fully and our team, you know, when we
talk about it uh on a more broad basis
listen, we're looking and saying do we
do we understand the value and what why
that product has value? And, it's really
that value to the to the consumer.
I think the the unique opportunity we
have and so fortunate is that
Warren comes into the office each day.
It's fortunate that we get to discuss
potential other opportunities that may
be out there. Bringing a different set
of skill sets.
But, in the end we're going to narrow
pretty quickly down to what's what's the
opportunity? Why why is it valued? Why
does the consumer, whoever is using it,
the whatever industry is it it it is,
what's
where where why will that company and
that product endure?
And, then associate with that where are
the risks associated with that? And,
that and that pretty much is how
Warren approached it, how how I approach
it. Um
So, the
when it comes to our existing portfolio,
yes, we'll always be well well aware of
what we've invested in.
But, as far as understanding those, the
opportunities and risks within them,
very comfortable that uh
have a strong view on that, and we're
comfortable where we're at. Thank you.
Did you need anything there?
>> No.
>> Okay.
Becky.
>> This question is for Greg, but I think
it's important that you take it while
Ajit's on stage with you, so he can
answer some of it, too. Uh it comes from
Zachary Phelps from Medfield,
Massachusetts, who writes, "Ajit Jain
has been described by Warren as
irreplaceable. He's helped build one of
the greatest insurance operations in
history, and has been the backbone of
Berkshire's underwriting discipline. How
are you thinking about succession
planning for Ajit and the insurance
business, and how do you ensure that the
underwriting culture, the insurance
moat, is preserved in the next
generation of leaders?" And Greg, I'll
just add for compression's sake, I I did
get questions about your succession
planning, too, so maybe you can add that
in there.
>> I don't know how I'm supposed to take
that.
Um
no, both succession obviously
successions an important um
uh topic, and I'll I'll come back to our
board both relative to Ajit and I, and I
touched on this earlier. I mean,
Ajit joined Berkshire in 1986, and is
the architect of our insurance business,
uh along with obviously Warren and input
from Charlie. But, it's a we've created
a franchise that's second to none, and
we couldn't be more proud of it. And and
as it was touched on, the culture and
the discipline within it within it is
exceptional.
Now,
uh
I found it really interesting and I I
you know, when Warren announced the
transition last year, and Ajit recalled
this,
uh the very first thing that happened
was we left that meeting, there's a lot
going on, and Warren said, "Let's to to
Ajit, but then also myself, let's get
the insurance managers together, our top
five along with Ajit, and with Mark
Hamburg, and let's let's sit down and
talk about the business, let's talk
let's discuss the the culture."
And it was a remarkable opportunity for
me to one, expand my knowledge base and
on the insurance side, and I um
obviously been working with Ajit for a
number of years and had other board
opportunities or had a
a wide understanding about but then to
spend time with Ajit and our team and
and have Warren's perspectives, it was
great. And that was literally the first
action Warren took.
And what I could see within that group
was a very deep group that of management
experience, insurance experience, and
they absolutely had the same values and
culture that
that Ajit has has highlighted.
Now, I think where it comes to culture,
as Ajit touched on it already, which is
it is challenging to keep a culture
where you maintain that discipline.
Uh
because as he said, in action in telling
people, you know,
"Take a few months off when they're used
to being active is not easy if they're
if they're that type of
uh underwriter or or or or selling
product." So,
that's the delicate balance, but when it
when it comes to Ajit, we're fortunate.
He's got an exceptional group that works
with him and and then also operates a
number of our critical subsidiaries.
They're they're deep in both knowledge
and talent.
I would then also
uh highlight our board takes the
succession issues very sincere seriously
both with Ajit and myself. Uh we have a
we have a plan they have a plan in place
and they discuss it. So, uh if Ajit were
unable to perform uh in his role today
or I was unable to perform, our board
knows what action uh they would take.
Um
Ajit?
>> Yeah.
Uh
So, in terms of the culture and the
underwriting orientation,
which is so critical,
there are a few simple rules that I've
followed over the years.
And it's come at a cost, but I think net
net it's still a positive. Let me just
lay it out in terms of how I think about
this issue.
Firstly,
we have a very small number of people
who actually get involved in the
decision-making.
My top three lieutenants in my
reinsurance operation, forgetting about
companies that that we acquire,
we have been together
for 35 plus years now.
And we've become friends. We And the And
the other thing to minimize any kind of
competition among these people and
stepping on each other's toes, we have a
compensation plan
that gives fixed salaries, fixed
compensation to the individuals as
opposed to having some complex formula
that results in
they get the upside and Berkshire gets
the downside. Uh
I try and stay away from that as much as
possible.
>> Thank you, Ajit.
>> a problem with all the compensation
plans I've seen.
Um
Then the other thing that is important
is
people need to have experienced
uh going through a tough time and the
fact that it doesn't penalize them.
We insulate them from the ups and downs
of the marketplace so that they feel
secure and they do the right thing.
And
yeah, so those are the elements that I
think allow us to have a long-term
orientation and not get sucked into the
latest fashion of the year or the day
and just do stuff for the sake of doing.
>> The compensation question such a a
critical point Ajit.
>> Yeah, right.
Yeah, the compensation thing having seen
all these programs over the years, I
remember having
mentioned to Warren at some point in
time. I said, "Warren, you give me a
compensation plan, I'll game it, you'll
not be able to figure it out for years
down the road."
Uh
and that's the problem together with the
fact that if the employees lose, they
want to go back and renegotiate the
plan. And if they win, they're happy to
walk away with everything.
Uh
so,
that's the big challenge.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Ajit. Thank you,
Becky.
We'll go to station four.
>> Hello, Mr. Abel. My name is Cansis and I
attend Elkhorn South High School in West
Omaha.
Mr. Abel, you may remember me from last
year and I'm here to question your
company's business model again. It is
compromising my future and the planet's
future. Mr. Abel, in your first letter
to shareholders, you wrote, "Berkshire
Hathaway avoids businesses that
undermine the fabric of society." But
Berkshire's electric utilities continue
to invest in fossil fuels that are
driving the climate crisis.
Can you tell me and my graduating class
when Berkshire Hathaway's utilities will
retire their fossil fuels, transition to
renewable alternatives, and stop causing
irreparable damage to the environment
and my generation's future? Thank you.
>> Thank you.
I I had a very
long and extensive answer last year to
the to the
question.
And and it isn't an important one, but I
think it's one we have to recognize
when we
and we we have
I'll touch on rail our rail too. We we
have certain companies where we very
much operate and and this would be our
utilities. It would be our our including
our our pipelines.
We operate as a steward of those assets.
We we operate as a steward of those
assets effectively for our states and
for our our customers.
And whenever we approach resources, for
example, that we may own or what we're
going to build, it's very much first and
foremost we absolutely
need to comply with the the current laws
that are in place including the federal
laws.
So we we know what those parameters are
and as we see federal law and state law
across our many states, but the federal
law
there there are things they do and there
are things implemented to
reduce the impact on the environment.
We're very sensitive to that and our our
teams are absolutely committed to both
complying and and absolutely doing it
right.
Um I would then add that if we're
discussing our facilities, for example,
across the river in in Iowa,
um
we we have plans on resources and when
we'll
um retire our our our coal units
potentially and and our gas units,
that's very much driven by state policy.
It's the state will decide, i.e. through
their policy legislature and through our
our regulatory processes, uh
how we'll operate what assets how long
we operate these assets.
Because in the end it's that those
customers that both uh bear the bear the
cost and bear the risk. And very much
we're we are
very respectful of that and as I said,
we're stewards of that. Do we provide
input into that process?
Absolutely.
So, for example, I I know you touched on
this last year,
but if I look at our Iowa utility,
uh
this is this changes every year because
of the load growth we've discussed,
but if we look at on a on a on a
12-month 365-day period,
uh
93 and it'll be very close on this.
Approximately 93% of our energy came
from renewable energy.
That's remarkable.
They they absolutely lead the nation
and we've done that in a way where we
could do it in affordable way.
But yes, we still have our carbon
resources there. We still operate our
our coal plants. We need them to deliver
uh
as I would call protection to the
system. I it stabilizes it and there's
peak times we need it.
But, do we use them less?
Absolutely. But, that's a policy our
state made many years ago, and we
provided a lot of input, as I said, and
and we've deployed the capital to um
ensure that could be delivered. But, the
reality is
um
state by state,
they'll decide what resources will
deploy to serve the customers,
and they'll and they'll also very much
provide us input on when we'll retire
our units.
The real challenge going forward and
it's it's well beyond Iowa, cuz I think
Iowa we and and our other utilities, we
approach it in a very prudent way, and
we've got
uh one I prudently we're doing it
consistent with our our state policy,
but we want to do it in a
call it a frugal way. We're trying to
We're not We're not building for just
sake of building. We're trying to do
things that are are that we feel are
best for our states.
But, but the challenge is when you talk
about the hyperscalers
and the data centers,
uh
the there's it's putting a lot of
pressure on the system, and there'll be
a you know, if you if you look at the
amount of gas units purchased, uh
there'll be an incremental amount of
carbon units used as we go forward if
that's going to be a valued if if
artificial intelligence and the
consumers want that, uh
that and that's a valued product. It's
going to put a lot of pressure on the
systems and on uh
the type of assets we use and and the
industry uses.
Ajit, anything on the insurance side,
cuz I know you've gone on the
insurance side as far as uh how what do
we ensure? How do we approach it?
>> Yeah. So, right now
in the insurance
sphere,
the supply is greater than the demand.
And that makes it very difficult
to be able to carve out a deal that
rationally is good for the buyer and the
seller.
Uh when supply is greater than demand,
then it's the seller that loses.
So, because of that, we haven't been
active in getting involved in writing
insurance for these uh new facilities,
the data centers.
>> Hyperscalers.
>> Yeah.
>> But, clearly
there is a surge in demand.
And as long as supply doesn't go crazy,
uh we will get a few days in the sun
sometime in the next few years.
>> Yeah.
Thank you, Ajit.
Uh very valid question, but again,
very wary
uh
proud, I would say literally proud, cuz
I think the one thing we've always
emphasized
across our utilities, across our
regulated entities, I would include
BNSF. They have to move certain product
that has certain risks and dangers
around it.
We are a carrier of that. We have to
that's a an obligation that came with
with that railroad. Just like our
utilities, there are certain things we
do
that are absolutely required, and the
key is that we do it consistent with uh
what's required both federally and at
the state level, and that we're
exceptional stewards of the underlying
assets.
So, with that,
uh
I just We're going to move Ajit, thank
you. We're going to move to
uh
our next session, but let me explain how
it's going to play out a little bit. So,
we're approaching 11:00. As we
transition, we'll we'll we'll move to a
NetJets video.
Again, just give you some
uh more knowledge on NetJets and Adam
Johnson.
We'll then take a break, but this is the
the the exciting part and we're very
fortunate Warren agreed to this.
At 11:45,
Becky and Warren will do an interview
backstage.
So, basically in 45 minutes, if you take
a break and then reconvene, we'll have
Warren on the large screen.
Uh, Becky is will interview him.
As we take the break, there'll be a
couple other activities. One, you'll get
a 3-minute warning before the 11:45, so
if you'd like to rejoin us, but you'll
be able to see it throughout the arena,
but it'll be a again a an interview from
Warren.
And then,
uh,
also during the break,
we often did commercials during the
movies and we could have incorporated
into the video. We'll have those at the
15-minute mark. Basically, at 11:30, the
videos of the commercials will play.
That'll be a 12-minute sec
reel of our various commercials from our
different companies. Be a 3-minute
warning and then we have the interview
with Warren and then we'll recommence
the third session. As we recommence that
session, we'll have a video from Katie
on BNSF that will allow our team to get
settled in here. So,
please, uh, enjoy your break as we go to
it and Becky and Warren, we look forward
to your interview. Thank you.
Welcome back. I hope you enjoyed the
break. Uh, Becky and Warren, thank you
for that exceptional interview.
Appreciate that.
Katie and Adam, great to have you on
stage. I would note both the videos were
um, extremely well done in that it gives
us a great understanding of
your businesses, but also you as
leaders. And I'm just going to start
with a question for each of you.
Um and then we'll go to the uh
back to the question and answer.
Uh
I think Katie, you well, I know you did.
You heard me speaking earlier.
Um I talked to our owners and and
shareholders are around our operating
performance and where we are.
Highlighted we were in fifth of sixth
last year.
We've now moved to fourth and and we
need to see we and we also talked about
needing significant improvement, a step
change.
But
the one thing I didn't really touch on
is I started talking about the the the
getting to that next level.
But as you touched on, you have 35,000
employees and
to move the organization to look
externally and recognize where do we go?
How do you take on that challenge?
>> Yeah. Thank you, Greg. And first of all,
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today and talk about our great company.
It's a pleasure to do that, Greg. So,
thank you. You know, we absolutely
recognize that it's important for us to
run an efficient operation,
to have a competitive cost structure,
and to continue to further close the gap
between us and our competitors.
You know, we have a an exceptional
leadership team in place
that understands the importance of
aligning the entire organization, as you
said, Greg, the 35,000 men and women of
BNSF, aligning them around that
operational excellence.
You saw that we made progress, as Greg
said, in 2025.
We continued to make progress in the
first quarter of 2026,
but we know that we have more work to be
done to drive that operational
excellence across all areas of our
company.
>> Thank you, Kitty.
And then, Adam, when I was uh
discussing your new role, and thank you
for taking on that role, and and as you
and and also retaining your role at
NetJets as the uh CEO there, so uh
a lot on your plate, and and all of us
here appreciate that. Um
but it's early going. You've been in the
role since December as the president of
consumer
uh products and then
uh service and retailing.
What What are your observations as your
your early observations uh across the 32
companies, and how are you approaching
that?
>> Yeah, in talking to the different CEOs,
I am
if you give me just 1 second before I
answer, I just want to make this one
brief comment.
Uh really to both Warren and and Greg.
Um I have been CEO of NetJets for the
last 10 years, but I I've been with
NetJets, this is my 30th year there. So,
on only at Berkshire could you feel like
the new kid on the block after being
here for 30 years. But
um you know, Warren has taught us a lot,
Charlie's taught us a lot, Greg's taught
me a lot. Um one of the things they that
they've said over and over is is that,
"Hey, bad news takes the elevator, and
good news takes the stairs."
And
I really understood that many, many
years ago. And until I became CEO, I
found myself uh on the elevator a few
times. And what they never told me was
what happens after you get on that
elevator. And I just want to point out,
as the CEO for the last 10 years,
there's been many times I've had to make
calls on things. And we run a big
business, and and I simply want to say
that what What after that is you have
the most unconditional support and I
echo uh all the CEOs that that are in
this portfolio. So I just want to say
thank you for that because it's not easy
delivering sometimes good or bad news,
but it's been phenomenal support.
As it relates to the the actual the
other 31 CEOs in our bucket, I have to
sort of start with conversation with
NetJets because people have been asking
me a lot in the last 5 months. So So
you're still CEO of NetJets, but how are
you going to take on this other role?
And I I think the journey starts with
with the team at NetJets. So many of
them are here and they're they're
incredible. I spent a lot a lot of time
over the last 10 plus years with them.
I was set up in that stage in the arena
in May of 2010 and it was a hard thing
to hear, but it was a truth and Warren
talked about NetJets and stated that it
was his toughest mistake that year and
but for the backing of Berkshire, that
we would have been bankrupt and I don't
like repeating those words and probably
shouldn't do it in front of an entire
room, but it's an important pause
because then you have two choices. What
are you going to go go do?
And so the team that's sitting with me
today and many people back home,
I do think we have a wonderful company
as Warren talked about with Charlie in
2023 and I just want to say to them
thank you because it's been a rough road
to do that and we've accomplished a lot.
Which gets me into answer your question
and and I
you know, I'll be honest with you. So
thank God I have NetJets because I was
able to fly around and see a lot of
these companies. Unfortunately, all 31
companies are not based out of Columbus,
Ohio. So I've been on our airplanes a
lot. Um and if I'm honest, I was a
little concerned about it. Many of the
CEOs have reported directly to Warren.
Um all of them reported to Berkshire and
then here comes this guy, you know, that
they're now going to be working with.
And I would tell you one of the things
that that struck me is how uh how wise
the CEOs are. They have the energy,
intelligence, integrity that Warren
always talks about. But I say wise
because of my concerns were quickly
allayed when I started talking to them
in the sense that they've been
listening. I know many in this room
don't know the names of those 31 other
CEOs, but they know you and they've been
listening. They absolutely understand
the playbook that is the the ownership
manual. By the way, this is the
almost today the 30th anniversary Warren
wrote the owner's manual. And in that
was sort of our business Bible on what
we needed to do. And I was really
pleased every one of our CEOs
understands that. They've been living
that
and that's going to make the interaction
much easier for me. So
I feel really good. I feel really good
about the form of the CEOs that we have
and I know that they have ingrained in
them the culture. Part of the culture
certainly is the ownership thinking, but
the stewardship that that is talked
about, we feel a massive and deep
responsibility to carry on the
stewardship and the legacy of Charlie
and and Warren and and work really hard
for Greg and his team. So
I feel good about it.
>> Great.
Well, we're very fortunate to have Cathy
and Adam in these leadership roles.
Again, it was a very purposeful to have
them on stage. We want them to have the
opportunity to engage with our owners,
our shareholders, and we really do look
forward to the the questions. So thank
you for joining us on stage again.
Thank you.
Becky, again, great to have you back.
Thank you for that interview and if
you'd like to start, thank you.
>> Okay, thanks, Greg. This question comes
from Chris Freed in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania, who wants to know how has
the current geopolitical situation in
the Middle East impacted Berkshire's
subsidiaries?
>> Sure.
I'll touch on it and then I'll I'll make
sure cuz it it it impacts really
in a variety of ways all our businesses,
but
um
what I'm most proud of our our
businesses uh we operate these
businesses for the long run.
Just like we do for obviously for our
shareholders we take a long-term
approach to
there's not many days and I used to joke
when I more had Adams role there wasn't
a day I woke up where there the phone
the phone wasn't ringing with good news.
Yeah, that phone rang you knew you're
going to have a bit of a challenge and
we have that portfolio but but that's
okay we'd be talking and we always
worked our way through it. And we have a
team that would lean in and we'd come
through and it could be anything and we
never tried to use that as a reason we
couldn't do something or get to the to
the right place.
And what I've seen associated with the
obviously the
the war in Iran and and the and the
various conflicts in the Middle East is
again a team has very much taken the
approach that that's the situation we're
in we can manage our business and we we
very much quickly move to
what's the best solution for our
customers.
How can we deliver and continue to
deliver what we've done to them and
what's their expectations around that
and and our teams will work incredibly
hard to come up with with solutions. Um
I I touched on LSBI the drag reduction
agent on the pipeline company. Um
they don't usually sell a lot of product
into the Middle East as far as moving
it's more a domestic based product for
Canada and the US when you think of a
drag reduction agent on pipelines.
Literally being
uh cargo planes of that that uh chemical
being moved in the Middle East to help
free up supply and and I remove that uh
some of that constraint. So, there
there's so many things that go on when
they start trying to figure out how to
solve uh
the challenge. Now, what I would say is
it doesn't mean there's not immediate
impacts to our businesses. If you think
of
companies in America around the globe,
petroleum is in got natural gas matter
is such a fundamental into input to so
many products.
And the reality is if you think uh I
touched on our chemical group,
their their input is
uh
generally a petroleum product.
And the output is the
the various products they produce
obviously that that are byproducts of
that. But, their input costs have
effectively doubled in a very short
period of time.
But again, we'll manage through that and
that's the the beauty of being part of
Berkshire. They know
first we'll take care of our customer,
we'll find the right answer, we'll
manage the challenges, and the value
creation will be there in the end. So,
there's some short-term pressure on our
chemical businesses. If you looked at
their
first quarter profits individually, they
would be down because they're or flat to
down because they've got some challenges
for example on the on the input side.
But, they're delivering what the
customer needs and that rebalances over
a period of time where our prices will
move up pursuant to our contracts. We'll
be treated fairly in the end in that
they'll reset and then man wind a little
bit slower, but the point is um
unfortunate situation and and we've got
you know, men of service and women of
service over there and and putting
themselves at risk. And and and and and
that in itself is uh scary because a lot
of our employees are are have family
involved, but
you know, as far as running our
businesses, it's really heads down,
we'll get through this, and we'll keep
operating everything for the long run.
And and again, it includes how we'll
operate our assets.
We're not going to put the asset at risk
to try to get to a short-term outcome
because uh petroleum prices are higher
or petrol petroleum prices are higher.
It's very much continuing to take that
that long-term perspective. Katie, um
obviously, it
it can impact demand and what's being
brought in on the on the coast. Are you
seeing that, or what else are your
observations?
>> Yeah, it's interesting, and and Warren
has said this in the past before, you
know, the railroad is a really good
reflection of what's happening in the
industrial and the consumer economies
because our loadings really cut across
all the various commodities. You know,
we touch agricultural products, we touch
coal, the industrial commodities like
cement and steel and aggregates.
You know, certainly our intermodal
business, which is such a big part of
our business, reflects what's going on
with the consumer. And so, we're seeing
the impact from the conflict in the
Middle East in a couple of different
ways.
First of all, I would say that if you
look across our various commodities,
it's created an opportunity for some of
those commodities just because of the
disruption in the supply chain.
In addition to that, you know, we see
commodities like aggregates and steel,
things like that that that are that are
favorable, and we're seeing an increase
in those.
But then, some of the commodity areas
that use energy
in the manufacturing of those
commodities are certainly being impacted
by the increasing fuel prices.
The largest segment of our business, as
I mentioned, is intermodal. And so, as
fuel prices increase, our intermodal
business becomes more competitive. And
so we're seeing an increase there
relative to
what's happening in the Middle East. I
would say in general though, as we think
about it, if fuel prices stay too high
for too long, it has an impact on
consumer demand.
And when that happens, that cuts across
all of our businesses.
>> And have you started to see that yet?
That obviously when you think of I
touched on it being an input to
many of our companies, but really
globally it's an input to so many things
and is that price pressure pressure
moves up,
obviously the
the demand side is challenged. Are you
seeing that yet?
>> Yeah, we're we're seeing some we are
starting to see that impact some of the
businesses. I would also say Greg, as we
talked to some of our our large
intermodal customers, what they are
telling us, some of the big retailers
are, the customers are having to make
choices now. So as fuel prices go up,
they make choices about what they're
buying. And so that's where I get back
to it if if it is a prolonged higher
fuel price environment, I do do believe
that we will see that customer impact
across our businesses.
>> Thank you.
Adam across your businesses, um
what are you what are you seeing? What
are you what are you feeling?
>> Yeah, I mean certainly, you know, when
you see
um
when you when you see the increases that
have occurred in the in the instant
spikes in some cases that occurred
certainly on the consumer product side,
on the real retail side,
um
it it has affected some of the demand on
that side. I would
um I would also tell you that you know,
we have also faced multiple times at
NetJets with a hundred, you know,
dollars a gallon or a hundred dollars a
barrel pricing. We see those spikes, we
see the demand. I haven't seen it on the
NetJets side. We went from
really the last two years from about
five to five forty a gallon. We're
seeing spikes up to seven a gallon.
I would tell you if I see that kind of
sitting at seven and a quarter, 7:50 a
gallon, then you'll see it start
impacting even on the higher inside on
the NetJets side. So, we're feeling it.
Um it's, you know, it's not the first
time we've had to deal with this. You
know, we're prepared to deal with those
things and make adjustments where we
need to, but it certainly is affecting,
I would say, some of the retail
businesses and some of the consumer
product businesses.
>> Great.
Thank you, Adam.
And thank you, Becky, for the question.
We'll now move to station five.
>> Good afternoon.
Manju Singh from Mountain House,
California.
Warren has spoken very highly of of both
you, Greg, and Katie. So, I'm grateful
to have you both leading our company,
and I'd like to ask each of you a a
question.
Greg, as you know, the Berkshire system
relies on decentralization.
Each manager runs their own subsidiary.
As CEO, which operating units do you
think need more oversight, and how will
you handle a manager who underperforms?
And Katie, as Greg highlighted, BNSF's
profitability lags its competitors.
With eventual technology advancements
and autonomous driving, trucking costs
will continue to to drop. How will BNSF
maintain its competitive advantage from
competitors and
new technology?
>> Great.
Thank you.
So,
associated with the letter I wrote to
all of you as owners, I highlighted some
important um as I've touched on values.
One of them was our decentralized model.
I also touched on risk discipline,
capital allocation,
and
when we
think of our businesses, we have an
exceptional group of leaders and
businesses, and yes,
they do own their businesses as Katie
touched on it in her video as Adam's
alluded to it and talked about it. Um
there is a great deal of ownership in
each of our across each of our
subsidiaries, and that's absolutely how
we'll continue to operate and see it as
as an extremely effective model.
They're closest to their customers. They
understand what needs to be done, and if
they think like an owner,
we get very good outcomes across the
group of companies.
I I would highlight though that with
decentralized
model, we we do not
um
take responsibility and I was one of
those I ran BHE. It's It's a great set
of responsibilities
or Berkshire Hathaway Energy. Shouldn't
be abbreviating, sorry. But when when I
ran it, that that autonomy meant you
meant you embraced it, and there was a
great amount of
accountability that came with it and
sheer pride that you wanted to do things
right. We've got a clear set of uh
when we talk about integrity and how I
started it, we have a lot of
expectations,
and that's where both on the uh
on the integrity,
how they approach managing their
business and and servicing their
customers, and I've said there's a lot
of external factors we we we can we can
observe.
But our primary engagement is with their
Are they managing the risk? And risk and
foremost, do they do they see themselves
as that chief risk officer you've heard
us
discuss many times.
Are they good allocators of capital with
the capital they have there? Because
even capital you have to manage your
operating expenses well. I view
everything, you know, that that when
when when we're spending money on a uh
it may be a capital expenditure, it can
be an operating expenditure. You're
deploying our our our shareholders'
capital. Are are we doing that well?
And we focus on that. So, that's part of
that equation of allocation of capital.
And
the reality is that if if we're seeing
um a situation where we're
underperforming or we're or we're seeing
some potentially poor decisions, that's
where we engage and and have a
discussion. And usually it's relative,
and I touched a bit on this with Katie,
it's relative to what we see externally.
And just really try and understand um
where our performance gaps are. And and
and then it quickly moves to
uh
and and we have we don't have the people
at corporate to go in and quote help.
So, it's not like we send in an army.
But there's generally some people within
our subsidiaries or maybe someone we
know that could help them with that with
that performance gap. Because we do
treasure
um continuous improvement and strongly,
as you've heard, believe in operational
excellence. And there's as I've said,
there's room for us to to get better.
And that's how we would approach the
situations where we see the gap and need
to close it. Katie,
maybe you can probably touch on both.
>> Um absolutely. So, thank you for the
question. And as I said, we absolutely
know that it's critically important that
we continue to drive an efficient
operation, that we continue to have a
competitive cost structure,
and that we continue to close the gap
with our competitor relative to our
profitability.
There's a couple of specific things that
we're working on. And it's really about
operationalizing the improvement that we
saw in 2025
into the first quarter of 2026 and
making sure that we're really
institutionalizing that. So, the first
thing that we really focused on in 2025
was
we knew that we needed to improve our
single car operational efficiency. And
when I say single car unit operational
efficiency, we run a couple of different
networks. We run our intermodal network.
We run our agricultural and our coal
network, our bulk networks.
And then the balance of it is what we
call our carload network, our single car
network. And that's where we we have
non-unit train. It takes a a lot of
operational focus. It takes a lot of
work effort. And it consumes a lot of
resources.
And so, anything you do to improve that
single car network
is good for all of your customers.
It frees up resources. It creates
capacity. It allows you to handle the
same amount of volume if not more
with fewer assets. And that translates
through then to the improvement that
you're seeing in the profitability. An
example of that is in in the first
quarter of this year,
we handled more volume than we did in
the first quarter of last year,
but we did it with 260 fewer
locomotives.
That translates into a more consistent
service product for our customers.
And it also translates into better
financial results, which is what you saw
in the first quarter of 2026. So, we
we're spending a lot of time ensuring
that we have operational excellence not
in all not in just all those other
networks, but in the network that frees
up resources and drives improvement and
operational excellence for all of our
customers.
The second area, and you heard Greg talk
about this earlier, was around our
technological transformation.
We really believe that in addition to
driving that operational discipline that
you saw in 2025 and into 2026
that
working with the the new BNSF tech
organization
to drive that next step level of
improvement.
And so you you saw units dwell in our
terminals
less time. That translated through to
the financial results that I talked
about. You saw velocity improve as well.
And so how do we leverage technology
then
to take the next step level improvement?
So I'm excited about what we're doing
there. We're literally attracting data
scientists
operations research folks and we're
putting them alongside of our operators
in our network operations center.
We're looking at things like uh digital
twins which gives us the opportunity to
model how we run the railroad before we
actually run the railroad.
We're looking at opportunities to do
predictive ETAs for our customers which
allows our customers to have a better
product.
It allows us to turn the assets faster.
And then last what I would say is that
we're just it's good old-fashioned going
to work on a on attacking the largest
structural cost buckets. We had a record
for the first quarter in our fuel
efficiency.
That's the kind of thing we want to do
because it makes us competitive with
trucks.
It is good for the environment
and it's good for our financials.
So those are the things we're doing to
close the gap relative to profitability.
Now your question about competing with
trucks
I would say a couple of things with
that. First of all
we have the largest intermodal franchise
of all of the railroads.
We have a unique relationship with JB
Hunt and we have been extremely
successful in converting over-the-road
freight.
We've done more of that than anybody.
So, we know how to compete with trucks.
But, your question about technology is a
good one.
And I would say that we in the past have
invested in a in a system called
positive train control, which is a
safety overlay that allows us to operate
the railroad efficiently.
As you know, we operate in a closed
circuit. And so, we have the ability
to your point, ultimately, to run the
train with fewer people than we operate
with today. And in fact, if you go way
back in time, we used to operate the
trains with five people on the train.
Now, we're down to two people on most of
our trains. So, the technology will
continue, just like most industries,
will continue to evolve.
And we're continuing to look at that as
well.
The last point I would say with that,
though, is that we also have to be
allowed to innovate. And so, we need
regulation that supports the ability for
railroads to be able to compete with
trucks. As you said, we know that there
are trucks out there running today in
our state in Texas along I-45.
We just there was just a pilot with
autonomous trucks.
What we have to be able to do is to be
able to compete compete with that and to
be able to innovate. And so, we're going
to need regulations that allow the
railroads to be able to do that. So,
that's how I think about
competing, ensuring that we're closing
the gap, as well as maintaining our
competitive advantage with trucks.
>> Thank you, Katie.
Adam, on that on that point, and Katie's
point, um
you know, you came
literally, Adam had left for a very
brief stint 10 10 years ago. Uh
and and and had a very senior role in in
NetJets and had been effectively been
recruited to be a CEO of another
business that was going public. and we
were fortunate enough to
uh, convince Adam to come back, but he
came back to a challenging situation.
The asset was underperforming. We had
billions of dollars of debt I backed
ourselves to the parent company, but it
was debt that had been incurred and some
real challenges.
Um,
when when when you think about how we
address underperformance and how do we
get a business back on track?
Um,
may maybe you just want to touch on that
period of time and and and that bringing
the business back and and and how how
you achieve that.
>> Uh, yeah, well, I one I will tell you
um,
you know, the one of the I came back on
June 1st of 2015 and that Monday Monday
afternoon and and many of the team
that's up here today I we got in a room
and I asked a question
about how many people really understand
sort of the bookends of our business.
Uh, NetJets is complicated. We're at
we're unscheduled. We fly to thousands
of airports.
Commercial Airlines will fly to 50 to
100 airports.
Uh, we fly to 150 countries around the
So, it's a very complicated business and
I asked the question to the team, um,
how many people do you think really
understand the bookends of our business
and I didn't like the answer. I won't
tell you what the answer was, but it was
too few and it sort of started there.
And what we did was we we really said,
you know, to build this culture the way
we want it, if I understand what you're
doing, you understand what I'm doing at
at deeper and wider levels, we're going
to do good things together. So, it sort
of started on that Monday afternoon and
when we we started building that back.
Um, I will tell you it was also a
reinforcement from probably from Greg. I
remember my first board meeting prep and
I was excited and we were starting to
kind of move and
and I was talking about uh, growth and
we're going to get this right. We're
going to grow
and Greg pulled me aside in a very kind
way and he said, "Why don't you pay $1
back to Warren and work on getting your
debt down. That was a teaching lesson.
Uh I took that to heart. I heard it
clearly, and I actually already knew
that. And so, we just started really
putting our blinders on, and we said
safety and service, safety and service.
Well, Warren bought NetJets after
becoming a customer in 19 uh '95, bought
NetJets uh 1998, and he did a video for
us that we still use. And he said, "I
want safety, and I want service." And
we've been really focused on making sure
everybody stays in that alleyway. That,
in large part, plus a lot of hard work,
um is why we're we're able to pay our
debt back.
Um we're able to pay uh cash back to
Berkshire Hathaway, and move our way, as
I said in the video, out of the other
column, and be first in the service
business, and I'm proud of that. So.
>> Great.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you, Adam. Thank you, Katie.
Becky.
>> Okay, this ki- this comes from Brian
Simpkins in San Diego, California.
The question is, has Berkshire Hathaway
considered seeking any tariff relief or
reimbursement programs for its
wholly-owned operating businesses
exposed to import costs, and how
significant is that impact across the
portfolio?
>> Uh let me let me start with the impact
across our portfolio, because it's it
it's very close to
uh discussing the the situation in the
Middle East, in that
yes, there were there was uh the
tariffs, and each business may have
fallen under a different uh
tariff for what they were importing, and
and we'd gone through it once already in
the in the first term of the adminis- in
administration, and
there there were lessons learned there,
so we were both better better prepared
in how to manage through it, and had
realigned a certain amount of our our
inputs. So, it
you know, that was valuable.
The second thing was it's as I described
with the with the conflict.
It was heads down and we'll just manage
ourselves through you know, listen,
there's there's some cost pressures
here.
We'll figure out how we're going to
continue to serve the customer. We'll
work through on on delivering what they
need and there has to be some reasonable
expectations on the other side that we'd
recover those tariffs from our from
through the uh
either through a direct contract with
them or through
the product we're creating and
and and that was a good approach in that
we just um
held our course and wanted to continue
to service them. So, they
yes, there is financial impacts, but our
team did a a really remarkable job of
addressing it and and really minimizing
the impact to any of our businesses.
Um as far as recovering it,
um
that would definitely be at our
operating level. They would be making
such a decision.
But but overall right now, our
perspective has been there's a there's a
lot to sort out when it comes to
refunds,
uh
what we're eligible for and and so at
this point in time, we're very much
taking an approach that um
uh
if it's appropriate, our team's will
evaluate it and and and again, it'll be
a discussion with our customers and and
and with a number of them. So, it it's
it's an operating subsidiary decision,
but we're not naive to it in that we're
encouraging them it's there's a lot to
be sorted out at this moment in time and
and and we're not pursuing them. That
doesn't mean we may not have a a
subsidiary now I'll look to our our team
on stage here that may be uh pursuing
one or seeking one. Uh Katie, anything
on
>> Uh
not as far as the the reimbursement, but
I would say just as far as the impact of
the tariffs and what we're seeing with
our customers.
Uh you know, I I would say that in early
2025,
we saw several of our our customers
pulling forward shipments in advance in
advance of the tariffs. And um you know,
we we certainly saw our volumes ramp up
at the beginning of 2025 because people
were were trying to get ahead of the
implementation of the tariffs. So, we
did see uh you know, an increase in
volumes through early 2025. That really
stabilized then in the back part of 2025
and then into 2026, I would say that our
customers have have really adapted to
the tariffs and adjusted to the tariffs.
With that said, it it it does cause some
uncertainty and I think where we see
that really showing up is, you know,
it's very difficult for our customers
from a planning perspective and I I
think it's keeping some capital on the
sidelines as far as investment in
manufacturing facilities and it's just
really the uncertainty of the tariffs
that that really is what we're seeing
reflected with our customers.
>> Thank you.
Adam?
>> Yeah, I mean I would echo both those
points. One um
I'd probably use uh
you know, Berkshire Hathaway Auto
Automotive, Jeff Rocker, who is an
excellent, you know, CEO of that
division. Um you know, his the new and
used sales are, you know, slightly down
in in Q1 of this year compared to last
year and part of that is this is sort of
that same effect from uh the tariff
buying that occurred a year ago to to
today.
Um I had to smile a lot cuz we were
collecting okay, that's just it's
changed every day as we know and you
manage through that and just
understanding the tariff bouncing ball
was, you know, a job in itself. But I I
had to smile cuz I was actually calling
our our CEOs just to get their take on
it and the 32 companies in the portfolio
consumer products, services and retail,
it's a stat that I love. They've been
actually been around on average 88 years
and only 0.5% of American businesses
have been around uh more than 80 years.
Our average in that sector from a
founding standpoint is 88 years and
several of this five of the companies
specifically companies that were founded
in the 1800s and when I called those
CEOs, they said we've been dealing with
tariffs for 100 years, you know, kind of
thing.
And so not being dismissive at all of
tariffs. The point is I look at the
whole tariff conversation as you're
always going to have a curveball. If I
think of the CEOs in the last
you know, seven eight years we've had to
deal with the global pandemic, the
highest inflation 40 years and now this
thing you know, the bouncing ball of
tariffs. So the businesses have done an
excellent job of managing through that.
I wouldn't put it in the fun department
of the things we have to deal with, but
I we're learning it and I think we're in
a in a pretty decent spot moving
forward. So
>> Thank you, Adam.
We'll move to station six.
>> Good afternoon.
My name is Amir Rehmani from Vancouver,
Canada.
Thank you for hosting us and thanks to
everyone at headquarters that makes this
weekend possible.
Um Berkshire's investments in the five
Japanese trading houses was passive.
Good businesses at good prices financed
by GPN.
Your Tokyo Marine deal is fundamentally
different. A 10-year joint M&A and
reinsurance partnership.
That's a level of operational
integration Berkshire has never done
internationally.
What does that look like in practice and
does it signal a broader shift toward
active international partnerships under
your leadership and to put you on the
spot, Greg. Canada versus USA in hockey,
who are you cheering for? Sorry. Sorry.
>> Now I'm in trouble.
Um
Yeah, Ajit did an exceptional job of
discussing Tokyo Marine
and and I'll I'll touch on it, but um
what and I and I teed it up a bit in
saying it is a strategic relationship
less than a uh financial transaction.
Yes, we like the 2 and 1/2% investment
in the Tokyo Marine and and that will be
a long-term
uh
investment. It's the type of investment
we put with our other five
investments in in Japan. We really think
of those as forever because it goes
beyond the investment and it's very much
around the relationships we want to
build there and you'll continue to see
that. Um
Ajit expanded on the underwriting
opportunity that we do jointly
participate in their their their risk
and rewards associated with effectively
also 2 and 1/2% of their book there now
and and that's again part of the
uh
financial transaction, but there's also
great deal of faith there. We We as Ajit
said
and really Ajit says and I take his word
for that, but it's
the you know, it's an exceptional
company and and and their performance
has been remarkable. So, we're we're
thrilled to have them and then the third
thing that was touched on was the
the partnership highlighted a variety of
things we how we would like the
relationship to develop
and that's not defined yet. So, we'll
continue to let that take its proper
form. They're the type of partner that
has the same culture, same values as us,
so there's little question it's going to
be exceptional for many years to come.
Uh but as far as pursuing an absolute
acquisition in in in insurance or
something like that, that'll evolve with
time and that would be obviously the
discussions as Ajit and the senior team
at Tokyo Marine would be having. And and
if such an opportunity materializes,
we'd be thrilled with it.
Now to the really tough question.
Canada versus US in hockey.
Um
I did find a way in
it's it can cause a lot of angst in my
own family. So,
um
I remember waking up that morning and
Canada was playing the the men, but I'd
already decided a little bit earlier
that uh
when it came to the Canadian men uh
versus US men,
Connor McDavid plays for Edmonton.
And uh therefore, I was going to cheer
cuz being from Edmonton, I would I would
cheer for the Canadian men's team.
And I've always followed the US women
and I love what a program the US hockey
and I I
love USA hockey and how they approach
the coaching and the and the development
of the youth. And I think they've done a
great job there. So, I chose to cheer
for the US women and it was the the
perfect outcome for me. So,
a little selfish in finding that type of
outcome.
>> I I I will say Greg Greg and I had an
Oilers-Stars bet last year.
>> Yes, true.
>> And we the losing person had to wear the
jersey of the other and I now own Oilers
gear.
>> Yeah, Kitty owns some Oilers jerseys.
And and unfortunately, this year neither
of us got to have that bet.
They're both on the sidelines very
quickly, but um
uh thank you for that question.
Uh Becky.
>> This question comes from a shareholder
who didn't want to be identified, but
it's a variation of a question that I
got from several shareholders. Is there
any future circumstance that you could
in very envision Berkshire divesting
businesses or being broken up? If so,
what are those circumstances?
The shareholder also writes note, I
don't want this to happen, but it's a
commonly discussed it's commonly
discussed among followers of the
company.
>> Yes, so the so
when we think of the question and I
think it's a good one because
we've always highlighted there's certain
circumstances that
we may not be the best owner of a
business.
We've touched on if there's labor issues
that we cannot resolve.
I would take it to the point then
further in my letter I touched on if
there's reputational risks that we're
not willing to
to ever have our owners or shareholders
of Berkshire experience and that we have
to
maybe the business has evolved, the
customers have evolved, but if our
if there's that type of situation
um
then then it that company does not
belong in the in the Berkshire family
and and it may be it may be a fine
business that can be owned by someone
else, but it may mean we don't own it.
Um I would then take it a little bit
further. I touched on um
a couple things or or one other thing
before I jump to that would be we've
often talked that if we have a business
that is unsustainable.
It and and and no longer generating
operating cash for our shareholders we
have to make some serious decisions
around that. If there's someone else who
could operate it and make it be more
successful both for the customer and for
our employees then we have to consider
that. Otherwise that business is
unfortunately in a place where
we can't just fund it and experience
losses. We would wind it down over a
period of time, but we'd look for a
better solution for our customers and
employees. So, that's always been the
case well, that that at least from my
perspective has always been the case and
how we'll continue to do it.
I would say we're taking it uh we take
the the obligation and and making sure
our capital is properly deployed,
obviously, very seriously. I touched on
the regulatory compact at energy
and that that has to exist and we have
to be if we have capital deployed there,
we have to get a fair return.
We have a a situation where we've
actually announced we're selling a
portion of Pacific Corp, our our
Washington state utility. Um
and and that's really a function of the
fact that we have a multi-state process
in Pacific Corp. There's six different
states and
each each customer's impacted in
different ways and I've already said
there's
we we very much focus on what's the
needs of our each state and how can we
best service them.
And unfortunately, we were in a
situation in Washington where they
clearly had policy that they wanted from
Pacific Corp and it was having a
significant impact on the cost of our
other states.
And as much as we would have liked to
see what we call a multi-state compact,
i.e. how do they balance all that, it
wasn't occurring.
And our other states were bearing costs
that they felt were not theirs, that
were being imposed by another state. So,
we consciously said this isn't working
for the six states. And the one state
who had very specific policies and
wanted them implemented, uh we chose to
exit. We found a very good purchaser uh
who very much supported and and could
implement what was required at that
state. So, there we there we have
evolved and it's a situation where it
just didn't make make sense for
Berkshire to be an owner of that asset
or our owners to be an owner of that
asset and it'll be I believe a better
outcome for the state and for their
customers.
So there are those situations where we
would
we would divest and we we we will always
approach things that when we buy
something it's forever.
When we acquire
a
utility we tell the regulators it's
forever but it has to be a relationship
that works and if it's broken we'll find
a better path both for the company the
employees customers and and obviously
for for Berkshire.
Yep. Okay. Yep.
>> Greg there's a second part of that
question though that gets at is there a
is there a point where some of the parts
or something is there a point where it
doesn't make sense for Berkshire to be a
conglomerate where you would break up
the company?
>> Yeah. So to the second part of the
question
absolutely not. We we I touched on it
earlier. We we we are a conglomerate
but we are an efficient conglomerate. We
we don't have layers of management. We
don't have a bunch of committees telling
our businesses how to run how they're
going to
you know manage your customer
relationships.
We try to the odd time create frameworks
so there's value shared across the
businesses so they're aware of what our
other businesses are doing and and
technology is that's one of them where
we like our framework now. We think it's
it it it's become it's very effective
across three of our businesses. So of
course we want them to understand it.
But we don't create layers.
I remember when Adam took on the role
I nicely said you know there there
there'll be no corporate group
supporting you
either in Omaha or amongst your own
team. We we he's got folks in NetJets
and they're all we step up and take more
responsibility including when I was uh
in that role or in the the the vice
chairman role. So, we
But, the one thing we don't do is create
layers of bureaucracy or
uh
other decision trees around it. And I
think so many conglomerates end up with
with layers and layers of cost that
don't add value in in in to the to the
overall corporation. I'm I'm even
careful when I talk about our metals
group and our chemicals group
cuz cuz they're a group in in
call it maybe uh
in my vision, I I mean they I I see
similar opportunities. I want them to
work together.
But, they don't have a corporate group
on top of them or anybody directing them
on what to do. They find ways to work
together cuz they have a lot of the can
have the same challenges, can have the
same customers. So, we see our
conglomerate structure working without
the bureaucracy and and and and bloated
costs. We see a great opportunity to
continue to move capital across those
different groups
in a very tax-efficient way. Other
people can't say, "I want to move
capital um BNSF is a great example. Um
yes, they they have a strong operating
uh results and they they generate
they're in a a cycle and they're they're
uh
uh business cycle right now where
there's a lot of capital we have to
deploy into it, but we also receive
substantial dividends from BNSF on an
annual basis.
We can take that capital and decide is
it needed in a different operating
business or do we see opportunities in
equities?
And if we don't see those opportunities,
we're happy to
not happy, but we understand the logical
home right now is US Treasuries. We we
think that's a good asset. We would we
prefer to see that deployed but
in a different fashion, yes, when the
opportunity presents itself. But it
allows us to really move that capital
across the group. So, I actually
the answer to the conglomerate is
yes, we understand we're one. We see it
operates very effectively and we do not
see ourselves
divesting of subsidiaries for that
reason or ever breaking off a group.
Thank you.
Okay. Station Station 7.
>> Hi Greg.
>> Hi.
Katie and Adam.
My name is Bo Wang. I'm here from
Chengdu, China.
On behalf of myself and my investment
partner, Shi Chi, thank you very much
for this opportunity.
And congratulations, Greg, on surviving
your first year as CEO.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm sure the seat feels a bit warmer
than it used to be.
As you lead Berkshire into this new
chapter,
what would you say is the most
significant evolution in your personal
framework for assessing cash flow
certainty and margin of safety compared
to Warren's?
And specifically, are you more inclined
towards technology companies that
exhibits the same robust cash flows?
Thank you for continuing the legacy of
Mr. Warren Buffett and Mr. Charlie
Munger.
>> Thank you.
>> So,
I I think I'll start with the important
part of that question. I mean, as far as
how Berkshire Warren thought about it,
how Berkshire thought around approaching
investments, quote our margin of safety
around investments, and how we how we
approach it. Um
we're we're absolutely aligned there.
And I And And that starts with our
culture and values and how we've
approached everything over the years.
Um
so if I go back to looking at
opportunities in energy and it may be in
an acquisition or we're deploying
significant capital.
It quickly went to yes, we understood
the opportunity,
but Warren
and and I'd want to have this
conversation,
um where's the risk? And do we really
understand the risk associated with
this?
And
uh I have a I have a really great
example is that we were acquiring NV
Energy in the um
uh
had the opportunity to acquire it and
Warren was actually coming back from
China
and and had been over there and I was
waiting for him to arrive and land in
Seattle and give him an update that we
had this potential opportunity. And I
very much knew the
the
the opportunity and what the
uh the value proposition was. I had
clearly had
three significant risks in my mind that
um
was anxious to discuss with Warren.
And in the in
Warren landed and I had a a short
presentation sent him asking him to just
give me a call. It was literally one
page, but just to really trigger it can
we have this conversation?
And the immediate conversation we had
was, yeah, the economics you'll you
couldn't agree more, understood them,
went right to the biggest risk. And I
was just getting ready to walk him
through
the two or three risks I'd seen and and
wanted to make sure we understood it and
were comfortable and wanted his input.
And the risk was fundamentally rooftop
solar and how would it disrupt that
business and disrupt our customer.
We discussed it. We understood it was a
a challenge.
I remember saying Warren, well, that's
part of the reason I'm sure we're we
have this opportunity to acquire this
public company that there is certain
amount of risk in the public and the
board and the and the management team
had decided
that they they didn't see the same
opportunity we did. But Warren went
right to it and it was all around the
risk.
And and that risk did surface 12 months
later, 18 months. We managed our way
through it. Our team did a great job.
But
so I don't see there being incremental
margins or we think of risk differently.
We think of them as in the Berkshire
mindset that the the we're going to
understand the economic prospects of of
this opportunity. And as I said, we
really go to that 10-year window
potentially and say, "What's the
business look like 10 years from now?"
And that and is there enough safety
margin 10 years from now? Is is what we
see at the outcome
do do we see an outcome and if we don't
understand what that looks like 10 years
from now, I know Warren would would say
this, I would say it, then we don't do
it.
There's no safety margin or maybe we can
adjust some numbers or there'll be
synergies or something of that. Like we
have to have a vision of what that's
going to feel like and look like. And
that and that really is the
the how we approach it. Now, touching on
technology companies,
we're not going to
ever say, "Geez, this is a a specific
sector for us or we need to be in it."
If there's something in the technology
sector or
in that group of companies and we
understand one of those companies to
understand again what their
opportunities are
and what we view as the economic
prospects for it and we have an
understanding of what those risks are.
That doesn't preclude us just cuz it's
in a technology sector or that, but it
would start with back to the
fundamentals of do we understand it?
Do we both the opportunities and the
risks?
And and then is it and then is it fairly
valued relative to that? And that's all
that's always going to be the approach,
so thank you for your excellent
question.
Now
Becky, if this is okay,
we're going to and and so please pick
your toughest question, but we're we're
beyond 1:00 now. This will be our last
question for today, so we look forward
to it and then I'll I'll have some
conclusionary thoughts and comments, but
thank you, Becky.
>> This question comes from Joseph Mattias
and he said Warren had Charlie's
partnership for most of his tenure as
CEO, which naturally reduced the risk of
subpar investment decisions. Who will
serve as the Charlie for Greg?
>> And and there there's a reason why
they're in the rafters together. That
was an incredible partnership and and
one that uh
you know, you you can't replicate, but
what what I would start with is that
very fortunate to still have Warren as
our our chairman.
And and that's very important and it's
and it makes for an excellent
transition.
Have a an exceptional board of directors
that I'm comfortable reaching out to any
of them individually,
depending on the circumstances and
either the risk we're dealing with or an
opportunity that may be present in
uh
any of our businesses or or one that may
be coming our way. So, we're fortunate
to have that exceptional group in place.
And And then, it really comes back to
our team that's in place.
And I said this when I was answering to
um Warren from Omaha
um that we want Berkshire to endure.
And that means, yes, I want to
lead Berkshire and I'll be a a strong
leader. I I strongly believe that and
and I'll I'll take Berkshire forward,
but it it will be
um as a as a
You always need a single leader and I I
think we strongly understand that. But,
you surround yourself with great people
and they're already here. I've been
fortunate on the non-insurance operation
to to operate with the
with with Adams 32 and the 18 that I
still get to interact with a lot. Those
uh including Adam and and Katie,
obviously, have an exceptional working
relationship with Ajit and fortunate
with that and would seek counsel
uh
regularly. Even Even as vice chairmans,
we would constantly have a conversation
around He may He may be making a an
insurance decision or I was making a
decision around one of our non-operating
businesses. And the first thing we'd
cross-check is, "How does it impact your
group?" So, have an amazing
uh
uh um uh
relationship and a val- and someone I
val- immensely value the input. And
then, across our CEOs, we're so
fortunate to have a great group that I
would reach out to any of them on a
specific circumstance and ask them for
their input.
And I generally know where they've dealt
with a challenge or a significant
opportunity, and I'd be the first to
seek it out.
And say, "Let's talk about it and figure
out our path forward."
And it may be that it was someone on
their team that really dealt with it,
and then I'd want to be talking to their
team. So, fortunately, because of
Berkshire and the way we were created
again, it is a
a unique structure, but we have an
immense amount of resources around us.
And then we have our our team in Omaha
who has supported Warren for all those
years. They're remarkable folks.
There's there's not a lot of them, but
they are good, and they're and they're
exceptional, and and we're fortunate to
have them as part of the team. So, it it
will be such that uh
Berkshire endures and will endure uh uh
as a as a team, but clearly with uh
um leadership. So, thank you, Becky,
that last question. Thank you.
So, as we as we wrap up today,
obviously,
I can't help but thank everyone for
joining us this morning and early
afternoon. Both as our long-term
shareholders or our
those that are are our newer
shareholders, and all again, all of you
that came for the experience. It's it's
greatly appreciated. We enjoy this
engagement.
It all comes together because there's a
an individual Warren has highlighted in
the in the past pulls together the
exhibit hall, pulls together together
everything here. I'd like to acknowledge
her, Melissa Shapiro. Thank you.
>> And then
the the light was over on that table,
but we do have
and we made this announcement in
December
our long-standing CFO Mark Hamburg is
retiring in June of this year.
We're very fortunate that then he will
stay on for an incremental year as an
advisor to our incoming CFO as
a personal friend advisor to myself. We
will have Mark's knowledge resource and
and it's immense when it comes to
Berkshire.
I like to
Mark has been our our CFO for 34 years.
This This Now this June of the following
June when he when he truly retires,
it'll be 40 years with Berkshire and
it's been such an incredible career and
and as Warren so he wears so many hats
in this organization. I mean he's he's
helping Melissa
Melissa's organizing and doing all but
when she has a question, she went to
Mark to look for the answer around be at
the annual meeting. He's our corporate
secretary. I I like to say and I
to replace Mark, we we hired a CFO, but
we also hired a general counsel.
It took It took two to replace him and
and and more than that. So
Mark, thank you for your incredible
contributions to Berkshire. Warren has
highlighted those and I can only echo
all that. Thank you so much.
>> Now lastly, again,
thank you for this remarkable
experience for all of all of us at
Berkshire. We we treasure what we call
owner's day,
that opportunity to communicate
around what's going on in Berkshire
because we're so proud of it, absolutely
committed to it, and and passionately
believe in Berkshire. But equally, the
engagement of all you throughout the day
yesterday into this afternoon, just
greatly appreciated. Thank you, and look
forward to seeing you next May. Thank
you.